figaro live bonsoir il et
21h54 exactement nous sommes en direct
emmanuel macron est élu président de la
république ils devancent marine le pen
comme il ya cinq ans mais je ne vous
fais pas les résultats aux niveaux
nationaux parce qu'ici ce sont les
scores au niveau local qu'on commande
chez avec alban alban barthélémy bonjour
le figaro.fr commandement des bonjour
bonsoir petit bourg je vous préviens
alban on est parti pour deux heures
ensemble et je suis prêt donc c'est un
marathon donc tenez vous prêts les gens
attendent beaucoup de vous les gens
attendent beaucoup qu'on leur donne des
réponses à ce que vous pouvez leur
expliquer ce qu'on va faire ici et bien
absolument s est très simple vous nous
vous nous donnez en fait tout simplement
chez un autre lors est le nom d'une
commune le nom de votre commune ou d'une
commune dont vous voulez avoir la
résultats oui ce qu'on fait c'est votre
cher aux parents qui on veut
ça peut être une grande ville ça peut
être une petite ville également nous on
cherche en direct vous cherchez voilà
qu'en regard de regarder on aura ce
petit écran tout au long a pendant
pendant ces deux heures par exemple
allemand vous venez d'où dites moi une
ville alors
[Rires]
soyons efficaces on peut commencer comme
ça je vous propose
d'aller voir leur lille alors je viens
pas de lille alors que vous savez très
bien que les grandes villes pour
l'instant les a pas tout le temps et
c'est là où je vous voulez exactement
vous md thibault parce que et enfin pour
les internautes qui veulent savoir
comment ça marche oui au moins ce qu'ont
à ces résultats en fait c'est assez
s'impliquer a expliqué qu' un résultat
dès qu un dépouillement est terminé et
que par ailleurs il est validé le
ministère de l'intérieur nous l'envoie
l'envoi en tout cas sur son site
internet on recteur ces résultats et on
les insère dans le moteur de recherche
que vous avez thibault oui alors vous
l'avez sous les yeux mais chez vous vous
pouvez faire la même chose exactement
pareil vous trouvez sur sur lefigaro.fr
sur la page d'accueil très vite vous
pouvez taper les résultats mais nous on
fait ensemble on s'amuse on révise un
peu notre géographie on trouve les
petites communes on trouve toutes ces
petites subtilités dans les différents
villages et villes de france et donc
allons-y cherchons lille m'expliquant
que c'est difficile parce que lille
c'est une grande ville les
dépouillements sont assez tardif ils
prennent plus de temps et puis les
bureaux de vote ferment un peu plus tard
mais c'est lyon par exemple on tape
lille ici dans le moteur de recherche
c'est très simple lille ici dans le nord
on descend et normalement alban vous
m'aidez pas tout de suite vous me donnez
une commune où on n'a pas les résultats
mais on a ici les résultats par exemple
du premier tour de jean luc mélenchon
d'emmanuel macro on peut comparer aussi
avec le premier tour on pourra aussi
comparer avec ce qu'il s'est passé à 5
ans regarder les résultats il ya cinq
ans en 2017 à lille c'était manuel macro
qui est arrivé largement en tête voilà
comment on fonctionne ici comment on va
essayer de trouver les différents
résultats dans votre commune celui a dit
votre grand père de votre grand-mère de
qui vous voulez alors je voudrais redire
bonjour à tous les internautes qui nous
rejoignent catherine par exemple
isabelle williams sur youtube notamment
à vous voilà on vous salue et on répète
à youtube alors le figaro.fr et facebook
exactement trois canaux sur lequel vous
pouvez nous demander les résultats dans
votre commune est justement
demandé une
gilles gilles roussel vous inaugurez ce
live exactement à l'invitation et nous
demandent ils vous demandent thibault
les résultats pour marie marignane
marignane alors marignane le célèbre
aéroport près de marseille c'est bien ça
voilà marignane dans les bouches du
rhône est ce qu'on ait des résultats à
marianne oui on les a on a l'airé les
résultats mariane regard des très bons
scores pour marine le pen un
64,44 % c'est elle qui arrivant en tête
dans les bouches du rhône devant
emmanuel macron donc 35 points 56% des
voix et ce qui est très intéressant
aussi regarder à marignane on peut voir
la participation est l'abstention
abstentions un peu inférieure aux 30%
c'est dans la moyenne nationale on va
dire on a voté à marignane comme à peu
près partout en france et puisqu'on va
regarder alban je vous prends à témoin
on s'attendait à peut-être un vote blanc
de la part des électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon on va s'attarder sur ces votes
blancs s'est maintenu le regard des 6 33
% de votes blancs et nuls dans cette
commune c'est assez intéressant de voir
que beaucoup de monde est allé voter
sans pour autant donner savoir un
candidat tout à fait précisons à dire
que tous ces résultats vous l'avez dit
il vous pouvez les retrouver sur
lefigaro.fr vous avez également des des
analyses les premières analyses qu'on
peut tirer de ces résultats des cartes
aussi je vais vous les mettre dans le
chatt regarder ses cartes par exemple je
vous en montrer quelques unes par
exemple vous pouvez trouver ici à quelle
est celle là attendez je des zooms un
peu pour tout le monde puisse bien voir
la progression de l'abstention entre les
deux tours vous pouvez voir par exemple
en bleu on sait moins obtenu qu'au
premier tour en rouge ans et plus
abstenus mais voyez vous avez des
premières indications voyez dans le sud
de la france notamment on s'est beaucoup
pape ce tenu notamment regarder ce petit
département là où je mets la souris il
me semble que c'est l'ariège jean
lamarre est arrivé en tête voiliers et
on s'est beaucoup obtenus dans ce
département c'est intéressant de voir
qu'on a des subtilités vous avez plein
de possibilités sur ses cartes
l'abstention au second tour de manière
générale la vancelle plus abstenus et
cetera et cetera et puis je sais que
vous y tenez et je vais le montrer tout
de suite regardé cette analyse de jérôme
fourquet sur le site ce nouveau mandat
sera marquée par une décomposition
politique avancée vous avez toutes les
analyses sociales sur le sur lefigaro.fr
et je lui en voulais remettre dont le
chat on me demande de sur facebook c'est
sophie qui nous demandent les résultats
pour la ville de montauban à montauban
on va à montauban allons-y alors c'est
pas une petite file à montauban on va
partir mais déjà les résultats
population 60000 habitants quand même
montauban et bien non on n'a
malheureusement pas les résultats c'est
emmanuel macron qui était arrivé en tête
devant marine le pen et on pourra
comparer en 2017 c'est et emmanuel
macron qui étaient étaient arrivés en
tête assez largement lui aussi on n'a
malheureusement pas les résultats
montauban on vous explique à nouveau
pourquoi c'est une grande ville et donc
les grandes villes on dépouille plus
lentement et en plus les bureaux de vote
ont fermé plus tard mais vous inquiétez
pas vous revenez qui nous a demandés
pour montauban parce que il revient dans
une alors c'est un souci c'était sophie
elle fit que les dents d'une heure et on
vous donne les résultats à montauban
alban vous y engager 1
ce promeneur a fait pas office / trop
société une des premières à nous
demander on la remercie dit pas autre
chose alors oui c'est fabienne fabiani
sur facebook et qui nous demande qui
vous demandent si beau les résultats
pour sar guy alors ça regorge nomine
sarreguemines regarder si la demoiselle
est résolument oui
alors on va parce que on va regarder les
résultats mais je veux qu'on révise
notre géographie albon ne sait pas où et
sarreguemines on va lui montrer dans un
instant mais d'abord les 108 si vous
mais on n'a pas les résultats vous me
donner que des gamins on n'a pas les
résultats alors c'est très désolant
fabienne sarreguemines oui désolé s'agit
de fabienne vous revenez est là aussi
sarreguemines claque on regarde on
cherche c'est dans l'est ici alors on
est ou à peu près on à sarrebruck qui
est pas loin on a et on n'est pas loin
de la frontière allemande sarreguemines
on est on est vraiment dans le nord
alalala vraiment à la frontière avec
avec l'allemagne oui on est on est entre
metz strasbourg 1 10 ont vraiment à la
frontière sarreguemines voilà on révise
tout ça ensemble ça a l'air très jolie
rien d absolument mais lui alors
fabienne peut-être juge vous redire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas forcément
encore le résultat c'est tout simplement
parce que eh bien peut être que le
dépouillement n'est pas encore terminée
les bureaux de vote dont les grandes
villes ferment plus tard que dans les
petites et donc voilà dès qu'on a les
résultats le ministère de l'intérieur
nous les transmet et on les récupère le
les équipes du fig est allé récupérer
nous du coup bien on l'aimait de l'autre
moteur de recherche et thibaut les
recherches thibout et moi on les
recherche pour vous voyez je m'amuse à
regarder des petits paysages de
sarreguemines très étonnant cet ancien
four à fayence à sarreguemines six
volets visite est allé une autre commune
aux deux parties alors je n'ai moi une
commune où on a des résultats comme
alors j'aimerais bien alors écoutez j'ai
villeneuve d'ascq par exemple nous
demande tu as aidé à sur youtube alors
villeneuve-d'ascq c'est pas petit nombre
annoncé près de lille 1 ils s'ennuient
le das kingson écoutez je ne sais pas il
faut écrire d'ascq c'est pas si facile
parce que vous le v6 gelés je les
regardais vers le nord dans le nord 19
d'ascq est-ce qu'on a plus de soixante
deux mille habitants à nouveau vous me
donnez une grande ville et
malheureusement n'a pas les résultats
vous vous moquez de moi
je voulais un
village que vous connaissez ou alors
j'ai lors qu'ils nous demandent
strasbourg mêlant ça va être le même
problème lors promis en chercheur à
strasbourg mais là maintenant le défi
c'est la première personne qui nous
donne une ville où on a les résultats on
la félicite on applaudira en direct sur
sur l'audition là vraiment on est mal
parti mais qu'on a qu'on dise aux gens
de venir c'est pas si faire écouter j'ai
alors écoutez je vous propose c'est
c'est
françois qui nous demandent les
résultats pour rouste rouste alors alors
attention c'est ce que je vais vous dire
si c'est pas si c'est pas si on n'a pas
les résultats ou stéphane quittet ce
studio et ben oui on a les résultats
house est une petite commune 550
habitants dans l'ariège et donc emmanuel
macron est arrivé en tête avec 56% des
voix ça fait 157 voix à oust devant
marine le pen abstention dans la moyenne
nationale vote blanc regarder 8 % de
votes blancs 2 55% de deux votes nuls et
j'ai envie quand même qu'on aille voir
ce qui s'il s'était passé il ya cinq ans
à oust est-ce qu emmanuel macron à
progresser ou régresser et on peut
comparer apparaissent avec le
comparateur du challenge il a largement
baissé regarder l'état 72 % en 2017 il a
baissé comme au niveau national
finalement oust vote comme la france est
peut-être l'un des bureaux de vote les
plus représentatifs de ce pays dit moi
on a autre chose alors merci c'est
gilles 1 c'est ça absolument on a dit
qu'on l'applaudisse est super belle
houle applaudissent et on l'a promu
voilà merci zizou mais l'autre pour vous
type je pense que c'est une petite ville
aussi ça va vous plaire c'est marie
emilie qui nous demandent l'ont alors je
ne sais pas comment ça se prononce
j'espère que la mariée le minipak
imagera on doit pas décevoir les gens
lons le saunier lons le saunier à boulon
ce sont les voiles absolument lons le
saunier dans le jura évidemment lorsque
le saunier et on a les résultats lons le
saunier à regarder c'est emmanuel macron
qui arrive en tête
4193 voix devant marine le pen sachant
qu'au premier tour eh bien
c'était également emmanuel macron qui
est arrivé quasiment ex-aequo avec jean
luc mélenchon donc la logique est
respectée si j'ose dire c'est emmanuel
macron qui est en tête je vais me faire
le plaisir d'aller comparez donc on a 10
63 % cette année pour emmanuel macron en
2017 il était à 72 % je pense que ça
risque de se vérifier tout au long de
cette soirée sans espoir qui baissent
peut-être qu'on trouvera une commune où
emmanuel macron a augmenté pour
l'instant on l'a pas dit moi on a
d'autres communes allemand oui j'ai
gilles l'a toujours sur youtube
d'ailleurs je veux d'ailleurs salué tous
nos internautes sur sur youtube et
réagissent beaucoup gilles williams
notamment qui commentent qui commente
régulièrement sur facebook vous êtes
très nombreux aussi alors attention à
bien rester courtois dans vos échanges
s'il vous plaît un oui mais en même
temps je les comprends si vous sauver
certaines personnes je peux comprendre
qu'ils soient les
résultats
prenez tout le monde assertion roselyne
on restera jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
s'il faut et bien et bien tiens pour
voir si beau philippe qui nous demandent
des résultats de bon soin qui nous
demandent les résultats de saint sauveur
dans les haute saône alors sans cela il
y en a beaucoup des saint sauveur
regarder alors dans les haute saône
alors dites moi
là que vous me posez une colle pas se
caler le numéro d haute saône c'est le
brave
60-60 quelque chose dans le 25
les autres c'est l'occasion de vous dire
que si vous nous donnez le code postal
ça simplifiera la démarche paraît là
c'est vrai et c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
que nasri a pas un saint sauveur quelque
chose parce que vous savez c c'est plus
simple ça on va chercher regardez je
suis en train de regarder également
saint sauveur jean les on était sûr
sarreguemines tout à l'heure
que vous pensez que c'est que cette
émission était truquée comme vous pouvez
le voir pas du tout non se permettrait
pas on prend peut tenir pour
310 300 dans les haute saône alors on
est où je vous le montre sur cette carte
oui on est on est allez au dessus de au
dessus de besançon entre berne et hand
aller dans ce triangle entre mulhouse
besançon et nancy saint sauveur donc 70
300 j'ai trouvé regarder si je tape le
code postal normalement je dois pouvoir
trouver
et on se moque de moi vous n'avez rien
on se moque de moi sans alors c'est
compliqué saint sauveur mais si je
trouve ça en sauveur regardez 72 qui
nous pose cette colle écoutez c'est
philippe alors ce qu'on peut peut être
faire thibault si vous êtes d'accord
s'est demandé à philippe de nous donner
le code postal / rex des mollahs
exactement philippe donnez nous un peu
plus de précisions sur l'endroit que
vous recherchez puis du coup comme ça on
pourra vous donner les résultats mais
alors j'ai envie de faire plaisir à
quelqu'un saint sauveur dans les
hautes-alpes par exemple et à saint
sauveur dans les hautes-alpes pour
regarder emmanuel macron est arrivé en
tête avec 59 38 % des voix ça
n'intéresse probablement personne sur ce
chat mais sache-le on peut trouver des
résultats dans saint sauveur à saint
sauveur dans les hautes-alpes retrouvez
dans votre zone bon passons sur une
autre ville petit bout si vous le voulez
oui il ya kevin na toujours sur facebook
qui nous donne les résultats pour mme
élèves dont le 49 alors dans le 49 vous
m'avez dit mais les aime le lex8
ça un seul en tout cas c'est ce que
l'internaute à l'android market m e l es
grect le y et sachets et je ne trouve
pas vous n'avez rien pas cette commune
alors sachez quand même que je salue
tous les internautes qui nous rejoignent
qui suivent le grand live la grande
soirée de la présidentielle avec avec
vincent roux et est brune d'audrey si
vous nous rejoignez ici on vous donne
les résultats dans votre commune vous
nous rejoignez sur notre sur notre live
à nous sur figaro.fr sur youtube sur
facebook on tape le nom de votre commune
et on trouve les résultats ci alban
daigne faire un effort parce que depuis
tout à l'heure que vous et bien non elle
est connue on n'a pas les résultats
jacouti à jacou j attends le gars est
avec lui
et bien c'est une des parts et dont le
département de l'hérault on sait les
régions qui héros regarder à jacou et
bien c'est tout simple c'est emmanuel
macron qui arrivait en tête 2002 sans
voix ça fait 64,25 % des suffrages
marine le pen est à 35,75 c'est assez
logique hein et puis l'abstention on a
bien voté à jacou regarder seulement 21
% d'abstention les votes blancs et nuls
assez élevé évidemment un presque 8 % de
blancs presque 2 2% à l'est de vote nul
et puis on peut comparer allons comparer
c'est ce qu'on fait ici sur ce live on
peut voir par rapport à 2010 est
emmanuel macron a donc réalisé 64 25 %
en 2022 en 2017 il était à 69 il a
légèrement baissé et se caractérise
également au niveau national voilà pour
les résultats jacou et c'était yannick
qui nous posait la question si enfin
vous faites un effort vous mettez au
niveau 20 des cas le grand live avec
nous pour nous regarder là je vois que
vous faites en élabore alors essayé de
mettre au niveau pas tout le temps nous
sommes une équipe de très haut niveau
chambre un peu mais c'est que toute
l'équipe de figuerolles elle d'ailleurs
alors j'ai une autre question une autre
commune oui pour vous c'est estelle sur
facebook estelle qui nous demandent les
résultats pour landerneau landerneau
dans la finition landerneau long des
rings d'actes manqués qui sacrait simple
avait exactement le film mystères
commune de 15 1914 habitants suspense à
landerneau qui est arrivé en tête c'est
thème annuel macron 71% des suffrages
28,35 pour marine le pen
abstention abstention assez faible
finalement à à landerneau regarder 22 68
% on a mieux voter coq au niveau
national dans cette commune de
landerneau je suis sûr que ces superbes
landerneau je vais je vais taper parce
que j'ai envie de voir des petites
photos de landerneau c'est le cas nous
le voyage un petit peu c'est exactement
alors évident d'avoir vous montre où
c'est l'an dernier en bretagne ça sonne
bretons 1 déjà landerneau on le voit
tout de suite regardez moi ce petit
canal c'est pas superbe magnifique voilà
aurions envie d'aller à landerneau avec
avec ce clocher on profite à moi j'aime
beaucoup cette petite commune de lord
ernaux sachez que la semaine dernière
dans ce cas il ya deux semaines on a
fait des petits concours pour savoir
quelle serait la plus jolie commune on a
fait plein de concours mais on
développera sa puissante cette soirée
pour l'instant landerneau le plus joli
commune qu'on nous ait donné nous
avaient mieux nous dit on va chercher on
tâte et on regarde les photos autre
chose alban et notre commune oui alors
philippe philippe henrique sur facebook
qui nous demandent des résultats pour
saint sauveur encore on l'a déjà eu six
receveurs mais alors c'est même philippe
mais c'est saint sauveur qui devait nous
donner vous savez le code postal est ce
qu'il a pu oui et il nous l'a précisé
voilà alors voilà et merci de me le
redemander thibault c'est le soixante
dix 370 mille trois cents alors c'est ce
que j'ai tapé tout à l'heure et je
trouve pas saint sauveur 70-300 ne
comprend pas alors on a un souci c'est
donc peut-être peut-être dont ils
arrivent dans la haute-saône oui mais
regardez seulement 300 t on à vrai
dilemme avec cette question peut-être
que c'est un hameau saint sauveur alors
je ne sais pas mais je il a essayé de
nous le préciser mais là je les voulais
philippe philippe vous nous avez donné
du fil à retordre mais quand même on est
arrivé voyez qu'on lâche pas nos
internautes en jeu mais alors il ya des
gens qui ont quitté life facile on peut
plus de santé leur envol zone mais
sachez qu'à saint sauveur en automne
c'est marine le pen qui est arrivé en
tête la première commune qu'on trouve
avec avec marine le pen en tête depuis
le début de ce direct
58,37 % des voix emmanuel macron 41,63
tient en 2017 que s'était-il passé dans
cette commune la marine le pen est
arrivé en tête c'était un peu plus serré
vous voyez qu'ils allaient faire un
meilleur score dans cette commune de
saint sauveur qu'il y a cinq ans voilà
pour pour vous philippe merci bravo et
vous avez bien voter dans cette commune
la plus petite abstention qu'on a vu
depuis le début seulement 17 %
d'abstention à saint sauveur alors à
présent être beau jean luc jean luc
français sur facebook bonsoir bonsoir à
vous il nous demande si on peut lui
donner les résultats dans sa commune sa
commune c'est rageant parker 11 c'est de
ce joli ça arpajon alors arpajon ça
s'écrit avec un h non alors cessons h à
rpa j ong au n 6 le long du rer c si je
ne fais pas d'erreur vous en savez des
choses
on est très cultivé
regardez on n'a pas le résultat pages
ont alors des fois c'est très
particulier on a souvent l'impression
que ce sont les grandes villes dans
lesquelles on n'a pas les résultats bien
repas jambon des mille habitants ce
n'est pas une petite commune mais on n'a
malheureusement pas encore les résultats
mais arpajon j'aime vraiment bien ce
petit nom donc on y repense dans une
petite heure c'est jean-luc c'est ça
exact jean-luc vous ne faites un message
et on est reparti on recherche arpajon à
nouveau on ne voit là vous vous rappelez
peut-être un jour profit thibault le
principe de cette émission vous donne
vous nous donner le résultat d'une
commune dont vous voulez avoir les
résultats et puis nous on recherche en
direct sur base des communes où on a
déjà les résultats c'est à dire la
dépouille et où ils sont officiels on va
pas vous donner des résultats qui
seraient pas encore entérinée exactement
ont recherché vous voulez donner c'est
le ministère de l'intérieur qui nous
envoie tout ça et hop on rendre sur le
site du figaro d'ailleurs il y en a qui
risque de nous demander je sais des
départements tant qu'on n'a pas
l'entièreté des communes d'un
département on ne peut pas donner les
résultats de ce département donc
malheureusement on ne pourra pas mais
par exemple les dom-tom je crois que
c'est possible on ira chercher un peu
plus tard dans la dans la soirée on ira
quand on ad'autres d'autres communes
peut-être à l'énergie david david et le
radar david alors bonsoir attention
c'est compliqué il vous le demande le
résultat pour leader il j'espère que je
prends garde bien ça ça sent la commune
en alsace non alors comment ça s'écrit
l'écouté dont j'essaye j'essaye elle est
attendue d eux leder zèle laideur et les
gelées alors que pas du tout les dlc
dans le nord qui exactement voilà les
dlc dans le nord et c'est dans le marine
le pen c'est vrai qu'ils aient fait de
très bons scores dans danser dans ces
départements 54 35 % des voix devant
emmanuel macron
45,65 % des suffrages l'abstention elle
est plutôt basse on a bien voté à
lederzeele dans dans le nord votre blanc
votes nuls c'est assez faible aussi
également dans cette commune tiers
allant voir on compare avec ce qu'il
s'est passé à lederzeele il ya cinq ans
eh bien regardez c'était manuel macron
qui était en tête changement de
changement de deux leaders finalement
dans cette danse est comme une feuille
est pas faute d renversement qui sont
étonnants du c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais bon finalement on s'aperçoit
comme au niveau national qu emmanuel
macron a fait un moins bon score pour
l'instant dans la plupart des communes
avec lesquels on a comparé et c'est
assez logique allez on enchaîne un autre
résultat alors c'est sophie zettel sur
facebook sophie sophie bonsoir bienvenue
vous nous demandez le résultat pour
nantes alors à sur l'ia il ya une astuce
surtout à bloc à nantes c'est une grande
ville et oui mais attendez c'est pas non
non tu
vois là c'est là où il est c'est le jeu
vous et vous emmener d'accord c'est que
c'est un autre nom a changé d'autres
nantes gênante en ratier part exactement
et bien c'est là où je veux vous emmener
alors ne pas nantes ont ratissé le
premier de votre liste exactement à
nantes tout seul est tout à fait viable
alors ça se dit peut-être non alors
c'est ce qui paraît effectivement alors
donc j'ai peut-être réponse est non la
commune voulais me cacher j'ai essayé
qui demande ça c'est sophie 7ème sur
sophie vous savez ce que vous faites
tout de suite sur facebook vous nous
écrivez comment on prononce non au
nantes pascal bondu n'importe quoi je
veux pas qu'on trompe les gens qui nous
regardent ce soir montre non non non
petit peloton les restes de l'aveyron et
bien emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête
avec 59 90 % des voix
363 voix et et marine le pen est donc
arrivé avec 40,10 % des voix on peut
voir qu'au premier tour regard de
l'abstention quand même c'est toujours
intéressant on a bien voté 21 %
d'abstention seulement au premier tour
c'était emmanuel macron qui avait pris
la tête devant jean luc mélenchon est
donc marine le pen logique respectée
finalement pour ce second tour vous
surveillez un ce que nous dit vous
m'avez dit c'est qu'ils sont financés ça
pour savoir comment on prononce non une
enquête comment écouter n'hésitez pas à
nous le dire sophie et jeu c'est promis
on le je le voulais à l'antenne pour
venir certains de ne pas ternir la
réputation dans le nord ou nantes
alors oui et je veux saluer les
internautes qui nous ont rejoints sur le
figaro.fr
notamment mafalda et puis également
anonyme 62 alors typiquement mafalda
vous n'avez le résultat pour pour dungy
sinclair alain à cb je connais figurez
vous alors parce que je lui donne sa
voix et ben voilà edinger sinclair je
connais très bien ça va vous faire ses
petits villages magnifique c'est pas
loin d'annecy joue vraiment ces superbes
si vous avez l'occasion de passer un
petit tête à dans les ca peut entrer en
compétition de la plus belle ville de
france a la plus belle mais le nom est
jolie annonce peut admettre que d'un gie
sinclair pour l'instant c'est le nom le
plus joli conte et a cherché depuis le
début de cette soir je vous l'accordé
vous l'accord ne fait alors je note
merci mafalda donc emmanuel macron en
tête à d'un gie sinclair
71,69 % des voix assez largement devant
marine le pen 28,31 abstention assez
faible finalement alors comparons avec
2010 est quand même à d'un gie sinclair
en 2010 7 76% c'est un peu moins bien
pour emmanuel macron mais qui se
maintient bien dans cette commune de
haute savoie de d'un gie sinclair a les
anonymes 62 aussi sur les anonymes
maintes fois annoncé et nous c'est
peut-être un nouvel internautes qui
veulent nous rejoindre parce que figurez
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai on le
remercie d'ailleurs s'ils veulent nous
rejoindre alors figurez-vous que là il
ya deux semaines on a aussi fait un
concours du plus joli pseudonyme pour
l'instant vous ne m'avez donné que des
prénoms un peu classique surprenez-nous
japonais nous alors cet anonyme
nous demander de vous demande si pour le
résultat pour genève
ge.n
ge n y a c'est une ville moyenne vous
allez voir donc on va devoir
voir justement si les résultats sont
déjà tombés ou pense journée dans le
dans le rhône et bien non
malheureusement regarder les résultats
sont pas encore tombés à à jeûner dans
le rhône on est désolé pour l'anonyme
mais il est puni parce qu'il n'a pas
fait de pseudo rigolo mais il revient
dans une petite heure pour jeunes et
avec la pseudo rigolo et on trouve les
bons on s'y engage dites moi alors vous
savez un le figaro.fr youtube facebook
on cherche on vous regarde partout album
vous regarde partout là des yeux sur
tous les réseaux sociaux ils me donnent
les communes et on cherche ses parties
dites moi libre d'écouter par exemple je
vous propose puisque vous avez vos mains
au dessus du clavier prêts à taper je
voulais vraiment pas les i
l'udc nous dit bonsoir quels sont les
résultats à liffré liffré l ifri qui est
une commune française située en bretagne
d'accord mais alors comment ça s'écrit
pas ce que sera la leaf réel i2f air aux
accents aigus liffré exactement en
ille-et-vilaine liffré regarder emmanuel
macron en tête assez largement à liffré
74,81 14% des suffrages marine le pen
25% se fait 3/4 un quart entre les deux
les deux candidats et abstention assez
faible aussi 17,99 % dans cette commune
de liffré
7768 habitants en 2018 dans cette
commune tient on a déjà regardé les
communes de bretagne la prochaine
commune qu'on a on cherche on va voir
des petites photos
histoire de voyager c'est aussi ça le
principe si vous nous rejoignez à
l'instant bah écoutez je vous rappelle
que le principe aux gens que c'est tout
simplement de vous donner les résultats
dans votre commune voilà vous nous
donner le nom
de la commune que vous recherchez dont
vous recherchez les résultats
éventuellement le code postal ça peut
nous aider c'est maintenant et puis bien
thibault recherche en direct dans notre
moteur de recherche dans le moteur de
recherche du figaro.fr entre il est là
regardez vous réponds plan et vous
pouvez le faire aussi chez vous sur la
sur la page sur la page du la homepage
comme on dit la page d'accueil
les anglicismes non mais j'essaie de
m'en passer mais c'est comme ça qu'on
dira c'est la homepage alors vous tapez
vous trouvez ci alban ne veut pas
malheureusement vous vous donnez la
parole et vous donner la main vous
chercher tout seul mais appliquez-vous
alban on essaye de répondre à tout le
monde alors autre chose inouïe
écoutez j'ai alors tenez j'avais
justement quand on parle de nulle part à
tout le monde ça défile beaucoup on vous
êtes nombreux à commenter et on vous en
remercie voilà merci par exemple à
vincent à wilton sur youtube et hier
d'écouté j'ai un joli pseudonyme pour
vous à thibaut geôles nazies sur youtube
c'est la magie des fous
on sait aujourd'hui je le prends
personnellement
cette élection était un peu folle en
tout cas un petit peu différente de ceux
dont on a l'habitude c'est vrai la magie
qui a fait son apparition dans cette
présidentielle avec notre ami gérard
majax sur notre ami wally du président
de la république en tout cas là mais
savoure magie ci permet pseudo il veut
qu'on lui donne les résultats dans
quelle commune à saint quentin à la
saint quentin lamon des cinquante ans
exactement département de l'aisne région
au de france alors saint quentin 50
l'aisne il est ici regardez c'est tout
simple saint quentin c'est pas la
commune de xavier bertrand 500 que si
1,5 en août et janvier vérifiez
habitants vérifiez mairie a et on a les
résultats à 50 alors c'est très serré en
regard des 50 53 % pour marine le pen
49.47 ça fait à peine un peu plus de 200
voix d'écart entre les deux candidats de
ce second tour abstention très élevé en
revanche à saint-quentin regarder 35%
des abstentionnistes dans cette commune
vote blanc votre nul c'est à peu près
comme comme dans le reste du pays et je
vous confirme effectivement que
xavier bertrand était maire de
saint-quentin de 2010 à 2016 sofia je
crois qu'il ya c'est là qu'ils votent à
chaque fois et xavier bertrand au
premier tour s'était déjà marine le pen
qui est arrivé en tête score très serré
je crois que c'est le lieu où c'était
plus serré ville divisée saint-quentin
bord dit moi on a autre chose alors j'ai
un pseudonyme plus classique mais non
mon très sympathique c'est vincent
antoine sur youtube vincent antoine
hraoui soir vincent qui vous demandent
si beau le résultat de parné sur roc
c'est une commune qui est située dans le
département de la mayenne alors j'essaye
comme ça mais par menée alors par un
homme armé alors attention à
l'orthographe est un démon chaque mot
compte non alors oui la java le parti
j'ai bien compris alors fait à r elle me
accent aigu tirait sur tir et rock
vous l'avez on va les voir parce qu'il
doit y avoir un roc ya une forme de
logique c'est bien possible et on va les
voir mais d'abord on donne les résultats
parné sur roc c'est emmanuel macron qui
est en tête assez largement 68 60 % des
voix dans cette commune de la mayenne
devant donc marine le pen 31 40 % des
voix abstention très faible bravo aux
habitants de parné sur roc qui sont
allés voter
16,67 % d'abstentionnistes seulement
allez on se prive pas à part n'est sûr
qu'on était sûr landerneau le temps
d'une photo le tour des photos déjà ou
ou et parné-sur-roc ça c'est important
parce que je pense que les gens qui nous
regardent ne savent pas forcément parné
sur roc ont des zooms un petit peu assez
palmans de laval regarder sud est de de
laval et donc parné-sur-roc les photos
il ya verts d'avoir une superbe petite
église à à part n'est sûr rock et
regardez moi ces communes ces maisons là
ça c'est ça c'est la france qu'on aime 1
c'est superbe c'est magnifique alors ça
a l'air ça al'air petit village de
campagne on s'y sent bien le sais pas si
c'est beaucoup de tourisme a parlé sur
wat mais ça a l'air très agréable très
bucolique à vivre avec même des petits
coquelicots au regard des dégâts même
pas si c'est rien ça si on en a bien
besoin c'est sur ce soir à la chaîne
alors tout autre chose alors une petite
question qui va qui va vous permettre de
préciser les choses le leadership
éclairé c'est ça
nîmes sur la nature voilà les idées plus
éclairés que nous au moins on est
content d'être encore plus éclairés que
lui exactement mais nous demande les
résultats sur paris a alors le
leadership éclairé paris c'est trop tôt
encore malheureusement parce que on a on
allait les communes les résultats dans
les communes un peu plus tard dans les
grandes villes parce que parce que les
bureaux de vote ferment plus tard et il
ya plus de monde donc les dépouillements
sont un peu plus haut mais on essaiera
il ya deux semaines on avait eu certains
résultats aux alentours de 23h45 dans
certains arrondissements mais promis on
trouvera ça et puis vous si vous voulez
vous pouvez même chercher demain
après-demain dans cinq ans si vous
voulez vous pouvez toujours trouver les
résultats donc patienter un petit peu on
n'a malheureusement pas encore les
résultats à paris mais je suis sûr qu'on
a des résultats ailleurs allemand mais
oui le gamer par exemple vous demande
sur youtube le résultat pour les
slovènes
alors laisse nos veines j'ai senti que
vous aviez un peu bafouillé
elle ne devait nous attend c'est et oui
dans le finistère à l'oreille le seul
mâle reis et l'oreille alors il va c'est
emmanuel macron regarder en tête à
lesneven 67 49 % des voix devant marine
le pen 32 51 abstentions dans la moyenne
nationale disons
26,50 % d'abstentionnistes alès neuvaine
ce qu'il a fait mieux ou moins bien
qu'il ya cinq ans emmanuel macron dans
cette commune allons voir 67 cette année
et non il a fait moins bien il a presque
perdu 10 points de pourcentage dans
cette commune de lesneven en bretagne
vous aussi un vous favorisez les bretons
à moins que il ya beaucoup de bretons
sur naples qui n'est pas impossible
n'est pas la tête on vous félicite mais
je suis sûr qu'il ya d'autres personnes
dans d'autres régions qui veulent avoir
des résultats venez on vous répond c'est
vrai alors vous êtes beau coup sûr sur
youtube notamment ainsi que sur facebook
à vous interroger sur le résultat de
cette élection présidentielle n'hésitez
pas à regarder sur lefigaro.fr à
l'ensemble de nos articles de nos
analyses vous retrouverez
notamment elle le lin te retiens de
jérôme fourquet goulag le montre et bien
écoutez jérôme faure qui voilà qui est
absolument passionnante qui détaille un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé ce soir ce
qui se passe depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois plusieurs années un haut niveau
électoral en france voilà n'hésitez pas
à la lire en complément de ce chat bien
sûr allait revenir ici pour discuter
avec nous et puis regardez on vous
montre ses cartes aussi tout à fait on a
on a des cartes qui nous donne partout
le vote blanc et le nul au second tour
par exemple regarder et eu beaucoup de
votes de votes blancs ou nuls influence
approche dans le dans le rouge plus on a
voté sans mettre un bulletin manuel
maquereau ou marine le pen dans l'
enveloppe regardez par exemple dans le
centre de la france ici beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de votes blancs et
nuls les pyrénées également on n'était
pas forcément très content encore se
regarder ses traits rouges aussi vous
avez toutes sortes de cartes sur
lefigaro.fr gars là la progression du
vote blanc et nul entre les deux tours
vous avez tous et très précis et vous
renseigner et vous revenez d'ardeur
derrière avec nous parce que nous on
vous donne les résultats dans votre
commune absolument alors justement
revenons-en aux résultats si vous si
vous le voulez bien j'ai maxime maxime
d'albin sur youtube qui nous demandent
si qui me demande s'il vous plaît
si nous pourrions lui donner la vie dont
bien les bains avec grand plaisir en
rien les bains je crois que c'est à ya
peut-être un achat effectivement hcng
hin bain exactement c'est bon la toile
voilà et oui 11000 habitants jeu mais je
sais tout par se regarder sur le site du
figaro vous avez tous la superficie vous
avez la population évidemment 2018 le
nombre d'habitants au kilomètre carré
c'est très très très précis et de vous
mêmes et non alors vous avez tout simple
et
je suis un peu emballé regardez
c'était parfait 90 ont été parfaits et
alors on leur ait dit endredi c'est très
étonnant défend la dea des communes qui
sont des communes de moindre importance
ont onze mille habitants
on oralement on a les résultats à 22h26
malheureusement on n'a pas encore les
résultats enghien-les-bains cette
commune du val d'oise et mais on
surveillera ça vous pouvez vous revenez
dans une petite heure on cherchera à
nouveau si vous voulez tout à fait sage
en compte vous donne un thibault et
chers internautes vous ne vous donne les
résultats qu'une fois qu'ils sont
dépouillés qui sont officialisées par le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est pas de
notre faute c'est la faute du ministère
de l'intérieur fait leur âme elle met
pas nos violons imperia
également prévu mais alex 66 sur youtube
voir avec il vous salue également il
vous dit bonsoir il nous dit bonsoir il
aimerait avoir les résultats de crise il
crée ville de crise il est dans mortes
et moselle s'est alors effectivement
lien ged et je les crédits en 1re la
moselle très simple alors petite commune
je crois que c'est la plus petite qu on
ait eu depuis le début on va faire un
concours trouvez-nous la plus petite on
en a une il ya deux semaines je ne vous
dit pas laquelle est vraiment tout petit
avec trois électeurs est ce qu'on peut
faire mieux trouver un ou deux électeurs
dans des communes si vous avez ce genre
de communes on prend alors kresic est la
plus petite commune qu'on a eu à
chercher ce soir est donc c'est marine
le pen qui arrive en tête 102 voix pour
la candidate du rassemblement national
ce qu'il apporte à 61 45% des suffrages
emmanuel macron se contente de 64 voix
dans cette commune
38,50 5% abstention 32 personnes se sont
abstenus et ce qui donne un total de 14
95% on a bien voté à crazy en
meurthe-et-moselle alors mailhiot nous
demande qui a gagné l'élection
présidentielle sur youtube alors l'a
écouté mais yoann je vous invite à
regarder ou simplement sur lefigaro.fr
ans et je vais je vais donner le
résultat vous casser le suspense n'a à
vous savez ce que vaut ce qu'on va faire
il ya un autre live c'est le grand live
la grande soirée présidentielle avec
avec vincent roux et bruno dray allez
vous nous fait une infidélité pendant 5
minutes vous allez les voir vous avez
résultat vous avez tous vous avez les
analyses
c'était manuel macro qui veut gagner
mais pas trop fort alors quelqu'un vous
a entendu thibault à quelqu'un vous a
entendu et oui sur youtube c'est vincent
antoine encore il vous prouve vous avez
d affection pour vincent qui a coûté 11e
comme un binôme et lui donna pour vous
parce qu'il vous demande oui les
résultats de rennes en grenouille qui
est nous dit il la plus petite commune
de la migraine en grenouille les actes
mais déjà c'est formidable je suis
obtiendra reinhardt grenier en reine
comme comme rennes la ville où comme une
reine lorraine comme rennes la gelée
vraiment grenouille alors déjà non mais
je crois que le contrat est déjà gagnée
pour le plus joli nom rennes en
grenouille c'est magnifique plus petites
communes d'où vous me dites alors
sait-on mayenne mayenne en jeu note
parce que j'ai un petit carnet et on va
vous donner le résultat à rennes en
grenouille mais pour l'instant rien en
grenouille devient la vie le plus joli
patronyme depuis le début de cette
soirée on fait des concours oui on fait
des concours on aime bien fait mieux que
rennes en grenouille mais ça va être
difficile 106 habitants eh bien regardez
c'est un village divisé rain man
grenouille 50% des suffrages pour
emmanuel macron 50% pour marine le pen à
ses 39 voix chacun s'épie leur regarder
ses piles c'est pile c'est pile c'est
pile voilà alors là je peux pas mieux
vous dire c'est vous avez vous avez vu
le sait comment ce cette bd d'astérix ou
le village et coupé en deux le grand
fossé vous voyez c'est tout à fait on a
on a un village c'est complètement
divisé en mayenne d'encre n en
grenouille avec une abstention parler on
a bien voté un 17,71 pensant allons voir
parce que je suis pris d'affection pour
cette ville de maintenant et je vois ça
vous touche vous annuel macro il a fait
beaucoup moins bien qu'à l'époque 1,3636
voix à l'époque 64% et je me permet même
d'aller voir comment on appelle les
habitants de rennes en grenouille alors
déjà renom grenouille à vous faites vous
fait un pari qui fait des hypothèses 7 à
paris rennes en gros c'est risqué déjà
regardé à ouidah on est on est donc en
mayenne absolument allons voir sur la
page wikipedia qui se charge les
habitants de rennes en grenouille
s'appelle à j'ai pas le résultat j'ai
pas le nom des habitants de rennes en
grenouille je fais un peu déçu
malheureusement bon et vous savez ce
qu'on fait c'est comment vincent antoine
il nous fait un petit message il nous
dit comment on appelle les habitants de
rennes en grenouille c'est super j'adore
cette commune bravo avance à antoine
dites moi un autre chose et francky
franquiste and sur youtube alors qu'ils
nous demandent alors attention ils nous
demandent les résultats de franche comté
du voilà alors là on va avoir un
problème oui alors on voit explique
merci nous nous reposer la question pour
avoir les résultats d'un département ou
d'une région il faut avoir les résultats
de toutes les communes malheureusement
ça c'est pas possible le soir même je
crois qu'il ya aucun département où on
peut avoir c'est ce genre de résultat
mais vous trouverez ça demain sur la
page du figaro.fr vous savez que ça
prend du temps les dépouillements
malheureusement on peux pas encore vous
donner des résultats en franche comté
mais si vous avez une commune en franche
comté vous nous la donne et on l'a signé
pas
alors houdré sûr toujours sur l'instant
nous demande si on peut lui communiquer
les résultats de les résultats de
valence dans la drôme précise-t-elle est
pas en espagne et nombre de patients
alors oui si vous cherchez aussi j'en
profite pour dire vous fait une passe
décisive on n'a pas malheureusement les
résultats des français de l'étranger
mais vous pouvez les trouver aussi sur
la page d'accueil du figaro.fr on n'a
pas sur cet outil là c'est très simple
vous trouver par exemple français de
l'étranger en espagne peut-être un peu
difficile parce qu'il n'ya pas encore
tous les dépouillements et par exemple
en amérique vous pouvez trouver déjà les
résultats plus demandés no 1 les dom-tom
aussi on peut trouver également valence
donc allons-y valence est une grande
ville et ça y est on a des résultats
déjà à valence rire des 64 mille
habitants et à valence c'est emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en tête 67 % des
voix devant marine le pen 32 abstentions
élevé à valence 32,11 % c'est souvent
dans les plus grandes communes qu'on a
le plus d'abstention voilà pour les
résultats dans je crois que c'est la
préfecture de la drôme valence il semble
alors gilles la rousselle sur youtube
nous demande si on a des résultats de
quelques villes en corse c'est possible
mais c'est possible mais il faut être un
peu plus précis jalousie calvi par
exemple essayons pourquoi pas calvi est
ce qu on a les résultats acquis à la vie
malheureusement quand je tape calvi je
trouve pas et
je vais trouve jean chercher notre
ajaccio est ce qu on a les résultats à
ajaccio ajaccio regard des 70000
habitants regardent et voilà on a les
résultats en corse à ajaccio marine le
pen 58,80 % des voix devant emmanuel
macron 41% des suffrages abstention et
normand encore se regarder 40 49 % à
ajaccio d'abstention on est et on n'est
pas très envie d'aller d'aller voter
visiblement il nous a demandé des villes
en corse et s'ils ont une deuxième
bastia par exemple parce qu'on a des
résultats à bastia oui également marine
le pen est en tête aussi à bastia 58%
des suffrages devant emmanuel macron 41
et là aussi on s'est beaucoup obtenu 43
% d'abstention dans cette commune alors
ça départ à ça vous débattez un beau
coup sur facebook sur youtube à propos
du résultat de cette élection
présidentielle est si vous voulez en
savoir plus et bien n'hésitez pas à
aller sur le figaro.fr parce que nous
ici on vous donne les résultats mais il
ya aussi toutes les analyses produites
par les journalistes du figaro il y a
aussi un autre là et vend courtil bout
d'ailleurs en ce moment même c'est vrai
vous pouvez le retrouver c'est bruno
dray et vincent roux ils ont des
spécialistes qui viennent analyses et
des sondeurs des journalistes figaro ils
débattent et puis également nos
journalistes sur le terrain dans les
différents qg notamment sur le champ de
mars où emmanuel macron vient de
prononcer son premier discours de son
second mandat vous avez toutes les
analyses vous pouvez évidemment débattre
nous on vous donne les résultats de
votre commune on essaye de vous aider
malheureusement nous le débat pour leur
sang ce soir on s'en passe mais on
s'amuse un peu quand elles sont rués way
nous on est les rigolos à c'est ça que
voilà
on nous a dit tout à l'heure on en a
cherché la magie des fous avec
un
état d'esprit voilà le soleil alors
dimension oui en gros pas sur facebook
on a man on man ont chaque cornac
bonsoir maintenant bonsoir manon je
marque kalhua bien d'écouter juin elle
nous le dira elles nous demandent l'aide
de l'état pour moussu à l'ordre mus m us
est une commune je veux un petit bout
dans le secteur au regard des actes sont
deux gars mais vous connaissez tous non
j'ai des sources c'est décevant et va
regarder à mios marine le pen est en
tête c'est serré là aussi un 52 97 % des
voix devant emmanuel macron 47% ça fait
4 155 voix pour marine le pen 404 pour
emmanuel macron abstention assez faibles
on a plutôt bien voter anus 263
abstentionnistes qui donne
21,88 % d'abstention dans cette commune
c'est allons comparer avec 2017 ça fait
un moment qu'on n'a pas regardé marine
le pen 52s qu'elle est arrivée en tête
il ya cinq ans et non c'était emmanuel
macron c'était aussi très serrée 1 vous
le voyez alors audrey pseudo sur youtube
monsoreau dre je suppose que c'est votre
pseudo audrey elle nous elle nous dit
que ce serait très intéressé par les
résultats de bagneux dans les
hauts-de-seine elle nous dit que sa
soeur manon y habitent ah bon il
embrasse manon par l'intermédiaire
d'audrey bagneux c'est une grande ville
un certain qu'on ait des résultats than
your vous rappelle qu'on a
ici on vous donne les résultats qu'une
fois qu'ils sont qu'une fois qu'on que
les votes sont dépouillés sont
officielles temps ce n'est pas le cas on
peux pas vous donner puis doit y avoir
plusieurs bureaux de vote à bagneux il
faut que vous rappelle il faut que ces
résultats soient donc soit à tester dans
chaque bureau de vote qu'il soit à
condenser envoyés dans les préfectures
qui eux-mêmes renvoie au ministère de
l'intérieur qui eux-mêmes renvoie sur le
figaro qui eux mêmes vous sens donné par
vos serviteurs ici c'est vous est ce
qu'on a le résultat non malheureusement
on n'a pas le résultat encore à bagneux
où jean luc mélenchon est arrivé en tête
au premier tour vous le voyez largement
devant emmanuel macron sur qui se sont
reportés les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon ça ce sera intéressant à
regarder allez une petite heure je suis
persuadé que dans une petite heure une
heure et demie on aura les résultats à
bagneux on les aura en tout cas le
ministère de l'intérieur nous les aura
communiqué on peut l'espérer alors sur
facebook à présent thibault on y
retourne un facebook lefigaro.fr youtube
absolument sûr que par trois canaux vous
pouvez nous poser
vous pouvez nous demander des communes
et puis on voulait recherche en direct
pour vous en donner le résultat gène
potentiellement une concurrente pour le
meilleur pseudo de la soirée alors on
rappelle sur l'instant on a le meilleur
pseudo oui alors le pseudo c'est la
magie des fous pour l'instant on aime
beaucoup à ce qu'on aille mieux a
raconté j'ai tata aurore à tâtons
lembras sur facebook oui alors les
quelques pièces qu'elle veut lever aux
aurores à écouter ou vous salue tout à
aurore bienvenus elle nous demande si
nous avons déjà les résultats de ré
outils à réotier alors c'est réussi
né dans les roses cm hautes-alpes
évidemment magnifique département les
hautes-alpes et et j'ai quelques photos
déjà je ne vous dis que ça danse il faut
que j'aille chercher les les photos de
réussite et sachez que c'est magnifique
bon alors je vais y aller mais d'abord
on regarde les résultats ensemble petite
commune aussi 1 59 0 6% c'est emmanuel
macron qui arrive en tête 75 voix pour
le nouveau président de la république le
nouveau qui continuera également
président sortant entrant finalement
marine le pen 2e 42 94% des voix on a
bien voté à réotier regarder
16,76 % d'abstention mais alors qu'en
revanche beaucoup de votes blancs on
n'était pas content 14,94 % de votre
banque vous m'avez demandé d'aller voir
les photos à réotier les côtés oui alors
après alors ambroise on arrive vers vous
dans un instant là sur youtube vous nous
demandez les résultats magnifiques où
les zones mais attendez on a quelques
photos tout de même assez superbe vous
avez vu ça c'est la fontaine pétrifiante
d'héritiers je lis à salaire salaire
magnifique a en effet regardez moi cette
vue magnifique superbe alors on aime
beaucoup je ne sais pas si c'est pas le
plus joli village qu'on a eu à voir
depuis tout à l'heure écoutez la france
est un pays magnifique mais ça on le
savait déjà dit oui sans doute
finalement regardez moi cette commune la
1c magnifique réotier dans les
hautes-alpes où emmanuel macron est
arrivé en tête parce que on s'amuse on
s'amuse mais c'est ce que les gens nous
demandent oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
alors soyons sérieux vous avez raison
thibault revenons résultat concret on à
ambroise qui nous a demandé déjà
plusieurs reprises embrasant youtube de
nous donner les compensées avoue avoir
d'avoir insisté exactement on vous donne
les résultats en bronze pour garches
garches garches avec un zoom exactement
garches cessé dans les hauts-de-seine
évidemment emmanuel macron est arrivé en
tête à garches largement un très très
bon score pour le pour le président 79
points 55% des voix 20,45 pour marine le
pen abstention assez faible finalement
23 13 % plus bas que la moyenne
nationale comparons avec 2017 parce que
là c'est un très bon score des manuels
macro est-ce qu'il a progressé est ce
qu'il a régressé il a régressé manuel
macro qui avait quasiment fait un
plébiscite dans cette commune de garches
ans en 2017 mais ça se confirme quand
même même si son score est un peu plus
bas cette année notre commune alors oui
et yacine sur route soyez les bienvenus
tibou il vous demande est le résultat
pour noisy le sec noisy le sec et rejoue
précise d'emblée cas noisy le sec les
habitants sont appelés les noiséens
voilà les noiséens écouter
apprendre des choses en plus avaient
fait c'est vrai
alors à noisy-le-sec malheureusement je
trouve pas vous ne l'avez pas mais alors
alors noisy attention avec avec un y
peut-être 1-1 mais alors je vais vous
mettre les tirs et voilà ça va permettre
de les avoir non alors noisy alors
comment ça se fait c'est très étonnant
parce que noisy le sec c'est quand même
pas une tente et le tristement la seine
saint denis le sec
alors si je tape noisy simplement noisy
avec 93 voyez peut-être l'avenir elles
ils trouvent effectivement alors 93 g
nous a regardés voilà vous pouvez faire
ça chez vous si vous trouvez pas vous
trifouiller avec le code postal avec les
le nom et vous trouvez noisy le sec est
ce qu on a les résultats dans cette
commune 44 mille habitants c'est quand
même une commune d'envergure et on n'a
malheureusement pas encore les résultats
à noisy le sec où jean luc mélenchon en
est arrivé en tête très très largement
au premier tour comme bien souvent dans
le 93 où il était arrivé en tête on va
on va surveiller très attentivement
parce que ça chez alban que marine le
pen est arrivé en tête en 2017 dans
seulement deux départements l'aisne et
le pas de calais on suivra ça dans les
dents les jours à venir dans les heures
à venir et à chaque fois qu'on aura des
communes dans ces départements
pour savoir si marine le pen a gagné
plus de département cette année étant
donné que son score a progressé parce
qu'on a autre chose et pour plus de
détails et d'analysé d'écouté c'est dans
le figaro de demain et sur lefigaro.fr
oui et thibault j'avais une nouvelle vie
pour vous celle août sur facebook lute
lute c'était si vite un joli prénom et
l'étonnant demande de combien a fait
marine le pen à mulhouse elle va pas
savoir combien a fait emmanuel macron en
tout cas elle est surtout intéressé par
le score de marine j'ai l'impression
mais de toute façon c'est corey les deux
manières génération ou donner une autre
vie vous êtes allés à l'école ou
ailleurs primaire finalement j'ai fait
quelques études se poussent alors
allons-y mais ces romans tom sachez qu
emmanuel macron a fait 65 80 % des voix
je vous laisse faire le calcul combien
de marine le pen un chalet à les tuer
avant je ne suis pas venez pas mon
professeur
dc oui c'est vrai je vois la référence
marine le pen elle a fait 34,20 % des
voix à mulhouse derrière donc emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en tête dans cette
commune du haut-rhin cette grange
commune voyez qu'on peut avoir des
villes de plus grande envergure 108
mille habitants à mulhouse et on a déjà
les résultats on va comparer avec 2017
70% il a baissé emmanuel macron comme au
niveau national comme à peu près dans
toutes les communes qu'on a pu voir j'ai
pas donné l'abstention à mulhouse parce
que ça intéresse les gens souvent et
regarder très grosse abstention à
mulhouse en 2022 pour ce second tour
38,13 % on n'a pas très bien voter on
n'avait pas envie de se déplacer dans
cette commune du haut-rhin 8 mois alors
sur lefigaro.fr je voudrais saluer
l'arrivée de dan 007 le demande d'exeros
0,7 voilà exactement oui
j'aime beaucoup alors qu'ils étaient de
jeunes hommes préférés alors là c'est
une question impossible mais c'est papa
de mission impossible vous parlez de
james bond si je vous réponds pièces
dans ce même a besoin j'aime beaucoup
j'aime voilà j'aime beaucoup brosnan
après les premiers à nos côtés mais
attendez attendez ça parce que je n'en
sais pas la question j'ai un nom deux
communes pour vous attendent une petite
commune ailleurs qu'elle gagne 0,07 nous
demande vous demande sur lefigaro.fr
c'est l'escarène l'escarène alors est ce
qu'ils avancent l apostrophe sk rennes
donc c'est dans le département des
alpes-maritimes
l'escarène en effet 240 habitants alors
là on va pas beaucoup on va pas avoir de
grosses de grosses de gros scores en
termes de voix mais regardez à
l'escarène qu'est-ce qu'on votait vous
attendez c'est pas du tout j'ai c'est
beaucoup plus grand de 1537 habitants en
un an en fait je me suis trompé ses 240
habitants au km² j'ai mal lu marine le
pen arrive largement en tête trois
quarts des voix presque 74 49 % des
suffrages devant emmanuel macron 25% des
voix
26,31 % d'abstention on va aller voir
quand même ce qu'il s'est passé en 2010
est dans cette commune de l'escarène où
marine le pen a progressé quand même
elle a pris presque six points en 50 et
2 007 qui nous dit que son james bond
préféré c'est alors il nous y mourir une
autre fois c'est peut-être un autre jour
mais c'est alors ça c'est un endroit
style une semblable et je pense que bien
je pense bien aidé en israël parce que
lui il a compris le james bond le film
c'est vrai parce qu'il ya l'acteur james
bond et le film ait pu les voir les deux
c'est vrai allons-y allemand alors on
nous demande le résultat d'une grosse
ville
gisi 40 cas liés alors écoutez gilles
ans n'est pas certain d'avoir ce
résultat parce que les grandes villes
est bien fermé leurs bureaux de vote
plus tard mais on peut essayer oui enfin
les bureaux de vote plus tard et puis à
plus de dépouillement plus de bureaux de
vote qu'il faut condensé mais c'est lyon
montpellier c'est peut-être un peu tôt 1
mais ce serait ce serait ignorer la
jurisprudence montpellier on pourrait
essayer toutes les villes de cette
taille 290 1000 habitants à montpellier
est malheureusement non regardez on n'a
pas encore les résultats c'était jean
luc mélenchon en tête assez largement au
premier tour à montpellier et au second
tour en 2017 c'est emmanuel macron assez
largement aussi en tête à l'époque on
verra le score qu'a fait le président et
le score qui a fait marine le pen
évidemment dans cette commune de
l'hérault la très grande ville très
jolie ville de montpellier on a autre
chose à la bandide - oui yvelines sur
facebook et nous dit bonsoir vous dit
bonsoir yvelines yvelines donc elle veut
sud peut-être une ville dans les
yvelines et vient pas du tout à ça et
c'est
un peu de monde le résultat pour s'y
laisser tant nouvelle aquitaine alors si
les c'est vous l'orthographier sci 2
elle a eu accès aux deux ailes comme ça
exactement tout à fait dit dans les deux
sèvres cette commune de steve est celle
d'être une toute petite commune où est
regardée 109 voix pour marine le pen qui
arrive donc en tête ah s'il est dans
l'est dans les deux sèvres devant
emmanuel macron 97 voix allez ça fait
voix d'écart entre les deux dents dans
cette commune c'est aussi une commune
très partagés on a plutôt bien voter
l'abstention c'est 21 71% à 6 les cette
année pour ce deuxième tour alors vous
êtes beaucoup à débattre du résultat de
la présidentielle sur facebook et sur
youtube je vous demande juste de
respecter quelques règles de courtoisie
les meubles voilà à la fois nous nous
sommes là pour vous donner les résultats
dans votre commune non seulement droit
de vous engueuler sur les deux notaires
voilà je vous demande évidemment de
rester courtois c'est sinon je serais
évidemment
intransigeant intransigeant avait aucune
intention évidemment de de masquer les
commentaires de personnes mais je vous
demande de respecter quelques règles de
politesse élémentaire sur lefigaro.fr de
toute façon on maintenant est ce qu'on
va faire on va demander qu'on va
répondre qu'aux gens qui disent s'il
vous plaît
on vous répond allez-y vous avez autre
chose sur le retour sur le lit rock ses
lyrics bbl sur lefigaro.fr nous dit
bonjour s'il vous plaît oui ça rentre de
vos critères et nous devons les
résultats pour majastre en alpes de
haute provence à les alpes de haute
provence 04 alors majastre majastre est
magie à l'aise
hamad
c'est une très petite commune la plus
petite commune au regard des neuf voix
pour emmanuel macron qui arrive donc en
tête dans sept communes de majastre
devant marine le pen et c'est cette voie
voilà deux voix d'écart cinq personnes
se sont abstenues vous pouvez savoir qui
c'est je suis sûr qu autour de vous
quelqu'un de votre famille n'est pas
allé voter je note majastre qui prend la
tête de la plus petite commune qu'on a
vu depuis depuis le début alors sachez
que dans notre concours et je vais en
lancer un autre que j'aime beaucoup
on eu trois concours ont parlé dans la
seconde mais en europe l'un des compères
rappeler pour ceux qui voudraient
essayer alors exactement longer
concourant en jeu c'est le plus joli
pseudo le plus joli pseudo pour
l'instant c'est la magie des fous à on
est toujours d'accord il nous a bien
fait rire le moment c'est le premier la
plus jolie le plus joli nom de ville
reine en grenouille vous vous souvenez
de gênes au chrono j'ai beaucoup ces
superbes rennes en grenouille est donc
la plus petite commune avec donc un
total de combien d'électeurs 1,9 +5 ça
fait quatorze +7 21-21 électeurs
seulement c'est donc majastre qui prend
la tête la tête où finalement la queue
de peloton de ces villes qu'on a eu à
découvrir je voudrais qu'on trouve parce
que on l'a fait il ya deux semaines le
nom de la commune la plus rigolote à le
nom de communes le plus rigolo je suis
sûr que vous avez plein d'idées autour
de chez vous de petites communes aux
noms rigolos vous nous le donner et on
cherche ici
je suis impatient mais moi aussi
alors il ya sur facebook ça faisait
alors excusez-moi j'ai mis un certain
temps à revenir vers vous savez ce n'est
pas ce qu'il ya beaucoup de commentaires
et de tomber sur trois canaux
différentes c'est vrai on est à la fois
sur facebook mais aussi sur lefigaro.fr
sur youtube donc voilà ça fait beaucoup
de questions mais je prends votre
demande vous nous demandez les résultats
pour garchizy garchizy c'est en
bourgogne franche comté garchizy comme
alors ah bah comme ça alors je crois que
je les exhorte je crois 12 à belley ain
ont alors pas du tout je suis dans la
nièvre là alors
alors c'est marine le pen dans garchizy
dans l'année mais alors allons voir
allons voir allons voir guerre j
garchizy avec un y au bout alors je
crois que c'est cette commune alors
garchizy jeux les jeux les gelées ah bah
oui mais figurez-vous alors là je plaide
coupable la nièvre et en bourgogne
franche comté donc tout va bien tout va
bien regarder ou et garchizy on va vous
montrer les résultats dans un instant
dans cette commune mais ça a l'air super
bien c'est l'occasion de vous montrer un
petit peu le droit de regarder ce
château de garchizy voilà château de
lavernée sachez le très joli et se rend
là c'est magnifique est ce que chaque
jeune vous êtes originaire de ce lieu
n'hésitez pas à nous le dire dans le
chat à ces magnifiques alors là je suis
complètement sous le charme mais ce que
veut cette personne c'est le résultat
marine le pen 56 84 % à garchizy dans la
nièvre en bourgogne franche comté vous
n'avez pas repris 1 vous m'avez laissé
m'enfoncer emmanuel macron écoutez je
demande à qui je trouvais ouais c'est
vrai on s'auto flagelle et on s'excuse
auprès de vous 43,16 % pour emmanuel
macron abstention dans la moyenne dans
la moyenne nationale
26,80 % d'abstentionnistes dans cette
commune de la nièvre alors on change
d'endroit geneviève sur facebook par
geneviève elle vous demande elle nous
demande le résultat pour la ciotat leur
attention c'est en deux mots oui bien
sûr la directive annoncée sur la côte
méditerranéenne saluant 35000 habitants
c'est une commune assez importante et
malheureusement on n'a pas les résultats
alors je sais pas pourquoi pour tout
vous dire on a souvent des problèmes
avec les résultats dans le var et dans
les bouches-du-rhône peut-être que dans
le sud on est plus lent qu'ailleurs non
c'est un cliché c'est faux mais c'est
vrai que je veux faire d énormes non
mais ils prennent le temps de bien des
pouilles et danser dans ces communes là
pour pas faire de bêtises
malheureusement on n'a pas encore les
résultats à la ciotat mais revenez dans
un moment on est encore allé un peu plus
d'une heure ensemble je suis persuadé
qu'on va pouvoir trouver les résultats
dans cette commune de la ciotat ou
regarder au premier tour c'était marine
le pen en tête devant emmanuel macron
malheureusement on n'a pas les résultats
encore deuxième oui je le fais parce que
parfois les bus si les bureaux de vote
ferment plus tard ou que le
dépouillement prend plus de temps bien
tout simplement
le temps que les résultats remonte
jusqu'au ministère de l'intérieur que le
ministère de l'intérieur valide ces
mêmes résultats et que ça remonte
jusqu'à nous vient et fort saint-louis
indélicats et on peux pas vous donner
des résultats tant qu'ils ne sont pas
validées officiels et complets et
complet exactement allez on continue
alors une autre demande
je vous propose on est sur quelque elle
cite là sur le figaro sur youtube
raconté je confonds pas ce que la rose
l'avez vous même temps je sais qu'il ya
du monde c'est quand même envie de
savoir exactement de remercier tous ceux
qui nous suivent en direct et qui nous
posent des questions qui nous demande
qui nous posent des questions qui nous
donnent des villes comme une île village
a en fait tous exactement alors j'ai
tanguy qui nous demandent sortant guy et
alors tanguy nous demande la vie dans
des robert lambert avec un thé au bout
la mousseline dans le département du puy
de dôme mais je vois ça je vois ça eh
bien on a des résultats à anvers et
emmanuel macron qui est en tête avec 55
10% des suffrages devant marine le pen
c'est assez serré 44 81 10 % des voix un
peu moins d'écart qu'au niveau national
mais on est quand même dans ce qui s'est
fait au niveau français l'abstention
également au niveau national assez
représentatif ambert de ce qui s'est
passé partout en france au premier tour
c'est emmanuel macron qui est arrivé en
tête devant marine le pen et devant
jean-luc mélenchon ambert c'est un bon
test vous voulez savoir comment votre
les français vous allez à ambert et vous
avez les résultats à peu près similaire
allons-y on a autre chose ailleurs alors
les autos vous ont entendu thibault il
vous propose plusieurs noms de vie
parfaitement improbable a
alors prenez moi est-ce que vous êtes
prêts oui
je vous entends déjà rire et je ride
avance écoutez il ya de quoi d'abord on
h 00 ce qu'ils nous demandent si
s'il peut avoir les résultats du village
2 y y y dans la somme à gré qui comme ça
y est exactement mais alors comment je
commence je fais moi parce que la
regarder siffle rien de sa fiche à
l'annoncé de l'accord mais si je tape
gré hommage au regard des y j'aime
beaucoup alors mais alors comment ça on
doit dire i ll y à l'orge alors de
commencer comment le nom de notre notre
ami alors c'est gervais gervais sur
youtube écrivez-nous est ce qu'on dit
j'habite à y où est-ce que j'habite à ea
ou à y
rester vous nous dites parce que ça
m'intéresse alors ah
oui y/y c'est marine le pen qui est
arrivé en tête 82 % c'est un très très
bon score mais regardez c'est une petite
commune quarante et une voix pour la
candidate du rassemblement national
seulement neuf fois pour emmanuel macron
12 abstentionnistes à y y hedroug ce qui
donne une abstention à 17 65 % j'aime
beaucoup aller ça ça me surprend je
savais pas qu'il y avait une commune
donc de la seule main c'est ça qui
s'appelait être peut-être il y a
peut-être d'autres villes en une seule
lettre à ses possibles si vous en
connaissez ou si vous habitez dans l'une
d'elles n'hésitez pas à nous en donner
le nom et puis on cherchera elle a beau
chercher on ramène en maintenant j'ai
envie de savoir comment on appelle les
habitants de y à vraiment vers la halle
sommes alors je vais aller voir regarder
déjà où s y dans la somme on est ouais
on est on est entre amiens et
saint-quentin vous le voyez et donc des
habitants direct alors wikipedia nous
donne des fois l'information regarder ce
panneau là ça existe vraiment à y est
donc figurez vous que les habitants je
suis là mais je trouve sa superbe des
habitants de y j'imagine dans la somme
s'appelle les ipsi l'oignon et le volant
a menacé alors ravi d'avoir appris ça
voyez alors on en apprend tous les soirs
et tous les jours et tout
particulièrement avec la commune merci
beaucoup j'ai revu bravo jérôme alors je
note parce que j'ai appris quelque chose
là on a autre chose oui sûr
youtube moulon alors je coûte et je vous
donne son sens de son message en
intégralité tivo a il le dit bonjour
bonsoir pourrait avoir le résultat de
cinq verges dans les deux sèvres je me
suis marié merci
félicite ana quantification voilà avant
que voici cinq verges et on va vous
obtenir les résultats de cette commune
si on les a déjà bien je suis sûr qu'on
a les résultats à sainte verge ils nous
provoquent un ct
bravo en chiffres le nombre à
1383 habitants à 102 verges en 2018 ou
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête les
douanes françaises c'est un boulot
bravo malraux 52 90 % devant marine le
pen c'est assez serré et donc
l'abstention à sainte verge 21 41% bravo
mollon vous prenez la tête du nom de
ville le plus rigolo c'est graveleux
mais on aime bien ça faut bien l'avouer
aller alors une petite pause dans 130
villes rigolo c'est un peu plus sérieux
sur le figaro.fr un autre internaute
anonyme mais qui nous a peut-être
rejoints très amoureux nous demandent
comment monsieur ou madame notée vont
soir monsieur modèle nous allons très
bien alors je mange un peu soi j'en
profite avait coûté alesi honteux quand
on est très heureux d'être là en votre
compagnie j'en profite pour rappeler le
principe de ce live tout simplement
c'est de vous donner le résultat dans la
commune que vous le souhaitez voilà vous
nous donnez un nom de communes
éventuellement le numéro du département
et puis thibout recherche en direct pour
vous et si les résultats sont déjà
officiel et uniquement à cette condition
est bien on vous en donne le résultat
est juste et on me dit nos internautes
qui peuvent le faire chez eux un
malheureusement j'avais beaucoup de
monde qui nous demandent peut pas
répondre à tout le monde non plus un
tiers du temps avec vos histoires des
villans y enfin bon donc on ne veut pas
répondre à tout le monde vous pouvez le
faire chez vous le figaro.fr c'est l'un
des premiers liens vous le trouvez tout
de suite vous tapez le nom de votre
commune et vous avez le résultat voilà
des mois d'autres analyses bien sûr sur
ces résultats c'est bien sûr dans ce
soit dans le figaro de demain que vous
pouvez acheter sur lefigaro.fr n'hésitez
pas d'écart des infographies et d
analyse je vais montrer je montrais
parce que regarder on en a des cartes
comme celle ci par exemple la
progression du vote blanc et nul entre
les deux tours vous avez ce genre de
carte vous avez plein explication vous
voyez que le vote blanc et nul à
progresser dans un très grand nombre de
communes 1 notamment dans le dans le
sud-ouest dans les pyrénées j'en avais
plein de cartes comme celle ci avec
plein de résultat tout est analysé et ce
sont des cartes qui vont être
progressivement remplies au fur et à
mesure parce qu'on n'a pas les résultats
partout ça va s'affiner au fil de la
soirée dans la nuit et jusqu'à demain
évidemment aller on enchaîne j'en viens
avec cette demande d'anonymes qui nous
demande pour sa grand mère c'est grand
voile à sa grand mère mamie il est bon
de dire plein de nom pour appeler sa
grand mère allons-y sa grand mère habite
une commune qui se nomme horn dans la
meuse et nous demande si elle peut en
avant le résultat horn comme ceci avec
un s exactement horn on est dans la
meuse donc pour la grand-mère de cet
anonyme et regardez le résultat du
second tour à 100 % des suffrages pour
marine le pen alors c'est une toute
petite commune cette voie mais à hoorn
ils sont tous d'accord tout à l'heure on
avait une petite commune c'était
difficile quand 50 tout pile est bien là
pas de problème bon à hoorn ils sont
tous d'accord elles ont voté marine le
pen ya trois abstentionnistes en
revanche dans cette commune et je crois
horn est la plus petite commune qu'on a
eu à chercher depuis le début un parce
que là je crois que ça fait 7 voix + 3 à
103 abstentionnistes c'est pas si facile
à dire ce qui fait dorn la plus petite
commune qu'on ait eu à chercher depuis
le début et qui détrône majastre qui
avait 21 électeurs donc horn cet anonyme
vient de prendre la tête malheureusement
il pourra pas venir récupérer son prix
vous savez c'est comme au loto il était
désolé mais merci de nous avoir demandé
sa anonyme sur le figaro.fr oui autre
chose
on
nous demande sur youtube chad bonsoir
j'ai soir jade elle nous demande les
résultats pour mon soûl mon soultz alors
installé au milieu alors oui bon avec un
thé au milieu à la vie un thé à la fin
mon saoul comme ça dans c'est donc dans
le val d'oise
et hammonds soultz eh bien regardez les
résultats c'est emmanuel macron qui est
en tête avec
56,67 % des voix
c'est 990 voix et marine le pen est donc
deuxième 43 points 33% des voix
l'abstention 26,66 vous nous rejoignez
sur sur ce sur ce live on vous aide à
trouver les résultats dans votre commune
la commune de votre grand-père
grand-mère qui vous voulez vous pouvez
même comparé regarder on va aller voir
par exemple en 2017 dans cette commune
de mons hoult 60 56 % cette année pour
emmanuel macron que s'était-il passé en
2010 7 66% saab et c'est donc pour le
président en cinq ans dans cette commune
du val d'oise allons-y bonne aux
internautes son joueur à
ils sont joueurs et vous plongez vous y
aller sans aucune hésitation maxime %
maxime maxime tente d'avoir tente de
remporter le concours de la ville la
moins peuplée a alors pour l'instant
donc on rappelle que ces horn dans la
meuse avec dix électeurs est ce qu'il
peut faire mieux côté nous propose la
ville de roches fourchard à rochefort
chat je crois qu'on l'a eue la semaine
dernière aux fourches à pour tout vous
dire vous la connaissez déjà alors
rochefort non j'ai à faire c'est d'être
là en cours de route roche fourche à à
mais alors c'est ce à quoi alain rochât
non j'aime bien air au milieu c'est pour
ça qu'on peut pas trouver voilà je les
rouges pour chats oui bravo bravo parce
que revanche ça c'est dans la drôme je
m'en souviens là il ya deux semaines
c'est pas la semaine dernière c'était il
ya deux semaines lors du premier tour
roches pour chat a tenu très longtemps
la tête de la plus petite commune et
regarder un rush prochain on est divisés
quatre voies pour marine le pen ce qui
porte son total à 57 14 % des électeurs
et puis emmanuel macron donc avec trois
voix 42,86 un seul abstentionnistes
trouver le vous lui dites que c'est pas
bien il aurait dû aller voter enfin dont
chacun fait bien ce qu'il veut dans la
sous l'immense amour mais des débats
entre voisins le alors lui c'est le
marginal du village il avait pas envie
d'y aller à rush fourche a donc dans la
drôme où on compte sept huit électeurs
bravo je pencherais qui reprend donc la
tête c'est maxime qui nous a donné ça
insectes blanc rouge fourche a donc dont
la maxime d'albin sur facebook et
anonyme nous dit que après tout s'il ya
des prix est bien il ou elle veut bien
rester à l'écouté rester avait résisté à
métaux vous pouvez nous demander
d'autres communes mais il vous vous
identifiez vous pouvez vous inscrire
c'est ça comment ça marche alors vous
pouvez une fois que vous êtes inscrit
sur le figaro.fr et une fois que vous
êtes abonné bien écoutez vous pouvez
tout simplement chers internautes
modifié sur votre page de profil votre
page de profil abonnés vous pouvez
changer votre pseudonyme c'est vrai que
par des fours mais anonyme parce que
voilà on n'a pas d'autres suggestions à
faire mais vous pouvez mettre un nom un
peu plus personnelle tout conte fait un
concours aussi et surtout à les reporter
un prix ça pour l'instant c'est la magie
des fous qui est toujours en tête on
aime beaucoup son pseudonyme bon
allons-y est-ce qu'on a autre chose
alors et si on trouvait une plus grande
ville on a eu plein de petites communes
est ce que quelqu'un nous demande une
plus grande ville et 23h on va commencer
à voir probablement devrait commencer à
tomber on peut peut-être recherché
montpellier a demandé tout à l'heure on
peut lier vous êtes optimiste
écoutez c'est mon tempérament pourquoi
pas vous avez raison vous avez raison
d'être optimistes
montpellier à 23 heures on a les
résultats n'ont malheureusement toujours
pas on n'a pas les résultats montpellier
mais regardez regardez je vais vous
faire plaisir on va aller voir les
résultats à montpellier de médillan
parce que j'ai envie qu'on a les
résultats de montpellier mais
montpellier de médillan en charente
maritime tout le monde s'en moque
peut-être mais regardez comme c'est
serré regardez comme c'est serré marine
le pen 56 74 % des voix dans cette
commune de charente maritime emmanuel
macron 42,26 vous pouvez trouver toutes
les villes tous les villages de france
dès que les résultats sont arrivés sur
le site du figaro allons-y cherchar
peut-être une ville intermédiaire pour
pour vous thibault ça pourrait faire la
faire la ville de dieppe diel c'est
carrie sur facebook qui nous on demande
des résultats et bien allons-y dieppe et
dieppe c'est une ville importante regard
des diètes 28 1561 habitants et c'est
serré à dieppe emmanuel macron est en
tête 52
75% des voix dans cette commune de seine
maritime devant marine le pen 47,25 %
des voix abstention
tout petit peu supérieur à la moyenne
nationale 29 59% tiens est-ce qu
emmanuel macron était déjà en tête en
2017 à dieppe oui il a baissé comme au
niveau national comme très souvent
lorsqu on vérifie lorsqu'on cherche des
communes ici ensemble alban alors sur
youtube on a man on man on chacornac
voilà elle nous demande si nous aurions
les résultats de bouquets
sait déjà c'est très joli ludique sa
grand-mère la télé au dépouillement et
les certaine qu'elle lui ment sur les
résultats a alors on ne peut pas créer
tout si familier ou non est ce qu on a
vraiment envie de s'immiscer dans ce
genre de projet
après écoute et il la vérité des urnes
oui oui ça c'est vrai ce bon alors le
dépouillement a booké qui est très jolie
c'est un joli prénom a book est donc là
aussi dans le gard eh bien ma non je ne
sais pas ce que vous a dit votre grand
mère mais a booké marine le pen est
arrivé en tête avec 66 voix devant
emmanuel macron avec 50 voix ce qui
donne 56 90 contre 43,10 et sachez qu'à
bouter il ya 38 ans abstentionnistes qui
donne une abstention à
21,84 % voilà vous voulez vous créer des
problèmes je
ne dissocie complètement de mon histoire
je suis totalement au service des
intérêts généraux communs fr et dans une
parfaite neutralité du réseau et le de
toute façon le site ne ment pas
associant les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur je le rappelle voilà puisque
bakou t on vous rappelle le principe un
dossier il est 23 heures et peut-être
des gens qui nous rejoignent maintenant
à cet instant aux gens comment ça se
passe et bien dès que les résultats sont
des que lily vote sont dépouillés qui
sont validées par le ministère de
l'intérieur eh bien nous les récupérons
sur le moteur de recherche du figaro.fr
que vous avez aussi à disposition chers
internautes et vous pouvez simplement
nous donner le nom d'une commune
éventuellement un code postal et thibaut
recherche en direct les résultats pour
cette commune est ce qu'on est reparti
regardez ça tu as comme ça hop hop c
est bien lui car dans ce cas bonsoir le
cas nous demandent des résultats pour
clermont clermont ferrand à grandes
villes on avait l'envié clermont ferrand
pourquoi pas at on déjà les résultats
lors à clermont il faut taper parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de clermont 1 clermont
ferrand donc dans le puy de dôme
évidemment clermont ferrand oui on a les
résultats voyant peut commencer à voir
des résultats dans des communes plus
importantes 146 mille habitants à
clermont ferrand emmanuel macron
largement en tête
71,68 % des suffrages devant marine le
pen donc évidemment puisque enfin je
sais pas pourquoi je répète ça à chaque
fois c'est forcément emmanuel macron
voilà puisque si vous nous rejoignez
aussi à l'instant effectivement est
alors bien emmanuel macron qui a gagné
l'élection présidentielle
si vous voulez avoir davantage d'analysé
d'ailleurs sur ce résultat il ya un
autre live en cours en ce moment même
absolument c'est vincent roux et est
brune d'audrey qui eux analysent ils ont
donné tous les résultats ils ont
l'érection dans les qg avec les
spécialistes du figaro qui viennent
expliqué analyser cette élection assez
particulière évidemment et donc a
clairement on regarde l abstention
importante
1,3280 2 % d'abstention dans cette
commune de 2 clermont on voit par
exemple qu emmanuel macron a récolté 31
31 1991 voix marine le pen 12640 et une
voix et il y à 24000 87 abstentionnistes
donc il ya plus d abstentionnistes que
des lecteurs de marine le pen par
exemple dans cette commune tout à fait
et puis voilà on a également sur
lefigaro.fr et dans le figaro de demain
de nombreuses analyses nombreux
entretiens vous pourrez les retrouver
dès ce soir en ligne lors de promotions
vous aimez bien faire la promotion mais
c'est vrai parce que les gens
travaillent très bien ici et vous avez
plein d'analystes vous avez plein de
cartes c'est très intéressant c'est très
interactif et vous allez voir vous
restez 30 secondes sur une carte et puis
vous en avez une autre plus intéressante
encore t'es vous resté toute la soirée
vous revenez un peu plus tard par
exemple on n'a pas réussi à trouver le
résultat dans votre commune tout à
l'heure on reste encore une heure
ensemble on va trouver d'autant plus
coudre et nous dit à l'instant sur
youtube que son live préféré ce soir eh
bien c'est celui ci c'est de l'autre
côté merci beaucoup audrey on est flatté
qu'est ce qu'elle nous veut quelques
choisel vocal veut qu'on l'aide un
résultat mais on lui a déjà donné des
résultats pour sa commune à leurs ordres
et si vous avez mais c'était audrey
s'était pas bagneux je crois qu'on
n'avait pas réussi je me souviens d'une
audrey à bagneux alors on gagne mais
c'était y'a pas longtemps essayons un
nouveau beau tenter n'ont toujours pas
malheureusement on revient on revient
reviendrait sur bagneux aller autre
chose promis on recherchera un petit peu
plus d'un mois il ya eu une grande ville
un clermont ferrand est ce qu'on a autre
chose et toumba sur youtube bonjour
thomas il nous demande le résultat pour
brassac brassac-les-mines brassac les
mines alors j'en ai beaucoup brassac les
mines c'est ici dont le surnomme
décidemment je sais pas ce que vous avez
avec le puits donne de suite essayé
d'alterner un peu parce qu'on va faire
des envieuses à brassac marine le pen
elle est en tête 57 46 % des suffrages
devant emmanuel macron 42 54 % des voix
et plus l'abstention elle est un peu
plus élevé qu'au niveau national 29 62%
je vous propose que la prochaine ville
on aille la chercher sur sur une carte
de france et puis quand on a essayé de
regarder quelques photos c'est avec
grand plaisir et bien juste écouter
justement j'allais vous proposé de
voyager un petit peu nous décentrer
puisque sur facebook fidèle exactement h
20 min r lement ghislaine résultats pour
la ville de mamoudzou mamoudzou qui est
située sur la côte
nous partons à mayotte d'actes mans à
mayotte mamoudzou où on a donc les
résultats à mamoudzou j'aime beaucoup
bravo alors là en plus je vous demande
de convoyage un peu vous vous écoutez le
haut mais c'est pour ça qu'au gré nous
félicitons arrêtez arrêtez de faire le
pari c'est moi qui ai dit va vite et
emmanuel macron 56,01 % des voix à
mamoudzou à mayotte devant marine le pen
quarante trois adultes 99% regardez
l'abstention énorme en c1 souvent que
dans l'outre-mer l'abstention est plus
importante 58,13 % d'abstention au
premier tour que s'est il passé jean luc
mélenchon était arrivée en tête chose
promise chose due des photos à agent la
halle aux imams ou du à mayotte
regardez-moi ça regardez moi ça oui ça
vous change de paris sa
mais oui mais oui ça nous laisse sans
voix ces histoires écouter demain je
prends pour mayotte vous êtes en
vacances
je me disais aussi je comptais bien sûr
vous regardez mahmoud doua à mayotte
évidemment et merci à vous fidèles de
nous avoir proposé
le nom de cette commune de nous avoir
permis de voyager un petit peu ce soir
un grand merci alors on a notre ville
alors c'était vous la cité sur facebook
un vous m'avez dit exactement et donc
sur facebook vous pouvez poser la
question sur facebook sur lefigaro.fr et
sur youtube on est sur youtube justement
jo ici nous demande le résultat pour
châteauneuf sur loire châteauneuf sur
loire alors là on est dans le cliché
presque un châteauneuf sur loire c'est
ça plairait aux américains sa
châteauneuf-sur-loire je vois le lit des
bons alors châteauneuf sur loire
allons-y c'est dans le loiret et à
châteauneuf-sur-loire emmanuel macron
est arrivé en tête 57 26 % des voix
marine le pen 42 74 l'abstention est
assez faible
23,04 % dans cette commune allez on va
voir ce qu'il s'est passé il ya cinq ans
emmanuel macron cette année on regarde
le score 57,26 en 2017 il avait fait 61
il atteint il a un peu baissé comme
comme partout en france comme au niveau
national et ça se vérifie dans à peu
près toutes les communes sur lesquelles
on se penche ce soir toujours sur
youtube thibault pire ou du 87 c'est
nous demande les résultats pour arnac la
poste et j'espère alors à mon avis ils
attrapent elle pour exister
pardon mais non il a entendu votre appel
un concours de la plus rigolote alors il
vous est pour l'instant on avait donné
le nom de la ville sainte verge mais
c'était un peu grivois arnac la poste
prend mais arnaques comme une arme après
carnac alors avec un art très attention
avec un hamac avec un c pour terminer
mac la poste j'aime beaucoup c'est
relatif aux c'est ce que beaucoup arnac
la poste et en haute-vienne sachez le
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête et ce
n'est pas une arnaque 51 80 % des
suffrages devant marine le pen 48,20 % à
arnac la poste on s'est déplacé 23 86%
une abstention un peu plus faible qu'au
niveau national je note donc
arnac-la-poste superbe alors là je ne
pensais pas qu'il y avait des communes
comme ça qui détrône donc sainte verge
je suis désolé mais oui hélas un petit
niveau quand même en arrêtons d'être un
peu bas de plafond arnac-la-poste ville
au nom le plus rigolo qu'on a eu à
trouver depuis le début est alors
attention thibault on va encore
continuer à monter à leurs jours est-ce
que ça va détrôner un mac la bonne alors
je ne sais pas on votera mais en tout
cas vous allez voir c'est encore une
autre catégorie les internautes sont son
joueur ça vous le savez déjà martin
pulby sur youtube on sort martin
surprenez nous et il nous demande si on
peut s'il peut avoir les résultats de
disney mme sur bruche 10 10 ajoute bonne
chance pour la prononciation mes nièces
manon et audrey n'y arrive jamais alors
côté je ne sais pas si je provoque
correctement je vais essayer de nommer
mais vous me dites pas repro non c'est
une fois et j'essaye de le taper sans
faire d'erreur alors attention soyez
prêts ces dix naïm sur bruche
disent même dit cela je suis le très mal
parti deans pour commence au quai d ing
im s game attachant des pays n s oui
ensuite un os c'est moi on est à
déchiffrer a gelé sur bruche ah oui dans
mes lives c'est une provocation
et bien c'est dans le bas rhin en même
temps on n'est pas vraiment surpris que
ce soit là sinon pareil alors qu'elle
est le résultat à disney / proches
j'avais comme je le dis de manière tout
à fait feu c'est très serré a dit je
n'aime sur bruche 50 39% des voix pour
emmanuel macron 449 voix ces sept de
plus seulement que marine le pen qui
arrive donc en seconde position dans
cette commune on a bien voté un 19 19 %
d'abstention seulement allons voir le
résultat en 2000 9 en 2017 pardon est là
aussi pour emmanuel macron ça un peu
baissé en cinq ans donc a dit chan sur
bruche alors thibault attention c'est le
grand retour d'un internaute qui tentent
de smac exactement la magie de fou sur
la magie des fours l'aiment beaucoup qui
est toujours en tête du pseudo le plus
rigolo exact alors lui faire un cadeau
on lui donne une deuxième commune ne
faut pas abuser actionnant c'est ce que
je me suis dit mais là tout de même il
vous lance un fameux défi il vous
propose de regarder la ville oui de
bohain en vermandois
il nous dit il vous est un célèbre
peintre en l'occurrence henri matisse ya
habité a alors dit on ont alors oui là
c'est une excellente raison un peu de
culture on élève le niveau à bohain
bohain en vermandois alors mais comme
leurs baux un bo h d'accord ay ay ay ay
d'exactement
vermandois vous la superbe c'est super
alors ça détrône malheureusement par
rennes en grenouille trouve le plus joli
nom qu'on qu'on est pour l'instant de
manière presque autoritaire parce qu'on
n'est que deux là vous ne s'est pas
démocratiques dans un grand soir
d'élection mais pour nous rennes en
grenouille est pour l'instant le nom de
ville le plus joli le plus élégant qu'on
a eu à chercher mais bon en vermandois
c'est superbe et c'est marine le pen qui
arrive en tête re 66 0 9% des suffrages
devant emmanuel macron 33,91 beau score
pour marine le pen dans cette commune
abstentions un peu au dessus de la
moyenne nationale
29,97 % j'ai envie de voir quand même
besoin en vermandois est ce que par
exemple on a des il doit y avoir une
maison matisse à bohain par exemple voir
en vermandois parce qu'on cherche on
révise un peu notre notre géographie oui
c'est fait part aussi c'est dans les
plaines où marine le pen un je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est l'un des deux
seuls départements et l'arrivée en tête
en 2017 fait bouin en vermandois
regarder alors c'est très joli la maison
familiale d'henri matisse vous verrez en
janvier la voici avec cette petite
palette de peinture et on peut pas la
manquer à ses très jolies j'aime
beaucoup magnifique ça ça a l'air d'être
la mairie et donc il ya c'est une ville
artistique bonbons en vermandois très
jolie merci beaucoup la magie des fous
alors martin est un petit peu déçu sur
youtube par notre prononciation mais il
nous attribue tout de même 3 sur 10 pour
les formes merci beaucoup martin
girard et
non mais en plus on se moque de nous bon
martin je vous l oeil un attention
donnez-nous une commune plutôt
martingale nous embêter alors nathalie
d'attali 20 sur facebook pour laquelle
nous demande plus sérieusement le
résultat pour ben y'a eu beynat
excusez-moi j'ai fait un document mais
attention sans mémoire aussi aston
martin vient nous dire qu'on prononce et
moi je suis à deux doigts lui donner
raison moi
y n acheter c'est pas si compliqué à
dire en septembre et dagana vous êtes
fatigué je vais un peu de retouches va
bien se placer à l'avant
on essaye d'aider les gens mais
allemands commencent à fatiguer je lui
dis c'est un marathon on est ensemble
depuis un peu avant 22h on ira un peu
après minuit donc vous avez aller 45
minutes une heure encore pour nous poser
des questions n'hésitez donc abena en
corrèze c'est la première fois qu'on
fait la corée ce soir emmanuel macron
est arrivé en tête 52 0 7% des voix
devant marine le pen 47 93 c'est assez
serré et donc l'abstention abena
19,27 % dans cette commune de corrèze
alors lors nous demande les résultats
pour paris et pour le 17ème
arrondissement alors là et c'est là on
risque d'avoir un problème ouais mais
essayons expliquer pourquoi mais alors
que tout simplement à paris vous devez
savoir que les bureaux de vote ferment
plus tard que dans le reste de la france
ils ferment à 20h comme dans toutes les
grandes villes ce qui fait que les
résultats arrivent forcément plus tard
le dépouillement est plus tardif que
ministère de l'intérieur récupère des
résultats plus tard dix mois également
et puis du coup on ne les a pas voilà on
n'a pas encore les résultats tant dans
le 17e arrondissement sachez qu'en le
17e en 2017 emmanuel macron avait fait
un carton 89 38 % c'est que pour marine
le pen c'est souvent plus compliqué à
paris mais mais je me souviens qu'il ya
deux semaines c'est un internaute qui
nous avait dit allez voir il ya déjà des
résultats sur certaines certains
arrondissements de paris vous pouvez
nous dira un parent léger grandes villes
si vous avez une grande ville vous
l'avez déjà chercher parce que vous
pouvez le faire de chez vous vous pouvez
avoir cet outil et trouver les grandes
villes vous nous le dites et puis comme
ça on transmet à tous les atouts les
internautes qui nous suivent bien sûr
parce que par ailleurs thibout c'est
l'occasion de préciser que le mot de
recherche qu'on utilise vous pouvez
aussi l'utiliser vous sur lefigaro.fr
vous chercher tout simplement ce petit
moteur de recherche et puis vous pouvez
introduire le nom de la commune qui vous
intéresse et obtenir directement le
résultat n'hésitez pas et puis n'hésitez
pas aussi à nous poser directement la
question est là pour exactement ah bah
oui et non nous on est là pour ça on
vous accompagne et on rêver notre
géographie
on écorche des noms de villes et on vous
fait qu
on essaye de faire en sorte de respecter
tous les noms de communes les bena vous
n'aviez pas le droit de vous raté
c'était facile du rebond j'avais encore
en travers de la gorge dites-moi alban a
bombardé vous avez des origines de cette
région là non non non jours alors j'ai
pas d'amitié quelconque avec les
habitants de beynat avant cela madame
aime beaucoup mais vous avez des
relations d'amitié avec ça vous êtes un
hôtel où ça s'est sûr à laurianne cette
fois ci j'ai pris un cette fois ci je
pense pas faire d'erreur de
prononciation de temps mais ça c'est
comme quand on raconte une blague qu'on
dit vous allez voir les super nom ne
fait jamais ça y est vous le résultat
pour cahors cahors dans le lot
exactement cas alors vous savez emmanuel
macron il a fait dans le lot son dernier
déplacement de campagne c'était c'était
vendredi 7 à figeac et donc à cahors
dans ce second tour emmanuel macron est
donc arrivé en tête 65 17 % des voix
devant marine le pen
34,83 % abstentions un petit peu au
dessus de la moyenne nationale mais on
est quand même
sensiblement dans ce qui s'est fait au
niveau de toute la france on peut même
voir les votes blancs les votes nuls
beaucoup de votes blancs quand même à
cahors regarder au premier tour emmanuel
macron était déjà arrivé en tête
légèrement devant jean-luc mélenchon
voilà pour les résultats à cahors comme
une importante 19 mille habitants quand
on a tout à fait alors louis nous
demande on se voir louis ou et maxime
laurie son journaliste préférée a alors
s'il est simple on va satisfaire votre
demande tout de suite maxime laurie
maximum ride donne les résultats tous
les résultats au niveau national sur
l'autre live celui présenté par vincent
roux et bruno drye où il ya des analyses
ou il ya des réactions en direct 1 1 ils
sont partout nous on se concentre pour
vous donner les résultats maxime leurs
idées sur l'autre live mais restez avec
nous ou si vous voulez on l'appelle je
lui fais un petit message y passent nous
voir voilà les mais il vous donne tous
les résultats sur l'autre à live on est
partout on essaie d'être le plus complet
possible pour vous donner les résultats
des analyses et puis pour être proche de
vous quel est le résultat dans votre
ville vous nous demandez quelqu'un veut
savoir le résultat dans sa vie d'alban
dites moi eh bien oui valentin merci sur
youtube dont saint valentin ça va enfin
nous demander l'abandon ou ta pour
bollwiller alors vous allez bien vu mais
alors c'est compliqué tendre fall of us
et c'est dans la banlieue de mulhouse
oui sauf que là je suis pas surpris y
voyez-vous quand j'entends un nom comme
ça est bonne avec douzaine bold exact en
bol ball winner mais c'est pas si
compliqué dans la banlieue de mulhouse
dans le haut-rhin et donc à bôle wheeler
marine le pen arrive en tête 57,22 % des
voix devant emmanuel macron avec 42 78
et donc l'abstention elle est assez
basse à abu louis l'heure dans le
haut-rhin 23 83 % d'abstentionnistes
marine le pen était déjà arrivé en tête
assez largement d'ailleurs au premier
tour dans cette commune alors l'occasion
de remercier tous les atomes qui sont
avec nous sur le faire on a beaucoup de
monde alors je vois des à la fois des
autres qui nous posent des questions qui
me donnent des noms de communes certains
qui débattent aussi des résultats de
cette deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ils peuvent ce n'est pas
vraiment notre rôle ce soir à 1 c'est
vrai
après n'hésitez pas alors peut-être
qu'on peut avoir un débat au sein d'une
commune et ça ça nous deux deux
internautes de la même commune petits
pains qui débattent ensemble ça en prend
d'accord là on veut bien s'en mêler
allez si vous voulez avoir des analyses
de cette élection d écouter n'hésitez
pas à parcourir le figaro.fr parcourir
le figaro de demain vous pourrez
retrouver tout ça bien sûr ce soir on
vous donne les résultats prince
également dès qu'on les a à tout le
moins et les résultats locaux 1
exactement puisque les régions c'est
encore un peu compliqué encore les
résultats partout donc voilà dès que
dans une commune on a le résultat
complet dépouille est validé eh bien on
vous le donne par exemple antoine sur
youtube soir antoine ne demande le
résultat de migné minier d'accord alors
mini comme ça ah non alors minier m iger
à oui j'ai raté le g voilà n l'accent
aigu alors il ya beaucoup de miniers non
il y en a qu'un minier minier tout court
aille à migné-auxances aussi mais alors
je pense que c'est minier sommes dans
l'inde exactement et amine et c'est
marine le pen qui arrive en tête 64 20 %
des voix 35 80 pour emmanuel macron avec
une abstention à ces fables
19,55 % des suffrages tiens que s'est il
passé à migné il y a cinq ans en 2017
allons voir marine le pen était déjà en
tête mais elle a largement progressé
dans cette petite commune de l'inde
retient allons voir minier en était à
bohain-en-vermandois la commune de
grandi où a vécu en tout cas henri
matisse allons voir où ces minier minier
je laisse que je les vois la gelée on
place minier dans l'indre sur une carte
de france et on est donc entre poitiers
et bourges dans le parc naturel régional
de la brenne sachez le voilà je
connaissais pas mais pas du tout alors
ça la retraite et de jolies marais on
découvre des lieux avec soleil reste un
grâce à nos internautes y faire un peu
gris mais des fois il fait beau haha
minier très jolie indé comme partout en
france évidemment dit moi un autre chose
certains oui florian sur les marchés
nous demandent des résultats de metz
mais à grandes villes essayez alors on
va voir peut-être qu'on les a pas encore
mais ça vous ça vous l'appelez c'est
pourquoi pas en mai à clermont-ferrand
joie que c'est la plus grande commune
cons et qu'on ait eu à chercher depuis
le début et à metz oui on a les
résultats
metz en moselle emmanuel macron
largement en tête 1,67 19% des suffrages
ce qui fait vingt-huit mille voix un peu
plus marine le pen 32% des suffrages
abstention très importante à metz 1 vous
le voyez 35 85 % d'abstentionnistes je
ne me prive pas de regarder ce qu'il
s'était passé il ya cinq ans à metz et
donc emmanuel macron était déjà en tête
mais il a un peu baissé là aussi pas de
surprise toujours sur youtube et romaine
il nous demande les résultats attention
c'est très sérieux de deux salles pis
c'est dans les pyrénées atlantiques
alors c'est très sérieux oui non mais
pourquoi me provoquer vous comme ça je
ne vois pas où est le problème vous le
plaisir dans vos salles pis
j'imagine leur attention salle avec un s
s à 2 l es pays deux espèces
à 2 l es pays de l'agenais ce
qui est cet internaute alors pardon
c'est iron mines il il remet nil qui a
tenté de prendre le nom de ville le plus
rigolo c'est bien ça monte sur le podium
c'est le débreak pour l'instant
arnac-la-poste quand même arnaque la
pasta en haute-vienne ça on aime
beaucoup on a eu sainte-verge aussi et
puis alors ce qui nous a surpris tout à
leur céder y est on n'a toujours pas su
comment on prononce un non dans la somme
mais on sait comment ça va être comment
s'appellent ces habitants les ips ilo
n'ya ainsi devenir exactement on vous
rappelle qu'on fait des concours on a
aussi le nom de ville le plus joli
rennes en grenouille on a la plus petite
ville refuge pour chats pour l'instant
dans la drôme huit électeurs et puis le
pseudo le plus rigolo la magie des fous
fait mieux salle pis les résultats c'est
comme ça qu'on veut voir attention le
thibault louis nous dit que pour metz
nous avons regardé ce nous avons regardé
seulement les le quartier de devant les
ponts alors on n'aurait peut-être pas eu
les résultats pour mai sera bon alors je
vais regarder alors on va on va y
revenir mais a donc à cette piste parce
que c'est quand même ce qu'on nous a
demandé oui 55 26 % des voix pour
emmanuel macron marine le pen 44,74
attendent sous abstention en dessous des
20% dans cette commune des pyrénées
atlantiques au nom rigolo alors il nous
a dit qu'on n'avait pas regardé partout
c'est ça exactement alors je suis alors
attendez
regardez-le oui on va regarder banon
mais saint messe j'ai vraiment le
résultat au niveau au niveau national
parce que ou essence au niveau national
au niveau global risk cent seize mille
habitants avec 28 mille électeurs pour
emmanuel macron 13000 pour marine le pen
abstentionnistes oui ça nous fait à peu
près à peu près 70 mille électeurs ce
qui me paraît un non très cohérent on
est vraiment sur toute la ville de metz
sur ce coup à et nous disent ils nous
proposent d'utiliser
57 milles pour le code postal alors je
vais le refaire parce que on a les louis
on va jusqu'au bout la démarche voilà
alors 57000 que je cherche alors j'ai de
la moselle mais non mais je metz
57 regardez jolie voilà foyers en haut à
droite je tape metz là j'ai toute la
population et je vous assure charles oui
qu'on est sur l'ensemble l'ensemble de
la commune de metz sait si je vous
assure garder 45 mille électeurs en
participation à une abstention à 25000
ce qui nous donne à peu près 70 mille
électeurs sur une commune de 110 mille
habitants c'est assez cohérent
finalement avec les enfants et que
ferrat voilà on a une autre grande ville
on fait tout écouter plus qu'une petite
ville gabin qui sur youtube on se
regarde on nous demande le résultat pour
la ville accrochez-vous de grands
groupes château le grand combe alors
grand tirait combes ah oui j'ai oublié
le tir et forcément ça peut pas marcher
alors effectivement grand'combe chateleu
excellent oui il faut ces trois départs
de baisser un peu c'est rigolo un
décevant on a toutes sortes de
d'écriture à grand compte donc
grand'combe chateleu c'est dans le doubs
sachez le et c'est emmanuel macron qui
en tête réfléchit c'est comment on
appelle les habitants sont
rentrés chez
eux emmanuel macron 65 23 % des voix
grand'combe chateleu marine le pen 34 77
% des voix abstention un peu plus faible
hausse et fun finalement 19 %
d'abstentionnistes les habitants de
grands comptes ce sont les grands
combats je fais le pari
perdu si vous m'en verdus cette fois ci
les habitants s'appellent les beugnon
les bonnes yonne voilà on mais quel
rapport alors nous écouter mais c'est ce
qu'on sait rien mais sachez par ailleurs
que ça a l'air d'être une commune
absolument magnifique alors on va le
montrer mais avec moi de vous dire que
j'ai du mal blason j'ai du mal à
comprendre quel est le rapport entre les
m'avait dit entre grand'combe chateleu
et les habitants de grand combe chateleu
sachez le c'est cher internaute
s'appelle les beugnon et les bagnoles
ça veut dire que ça n'a aucun sens en
télé mais on embrasse les besoins et les
benoît là et on remercie notera tonneau
de nous avoir posé la question au regard
des grands comptes alors ça a l'air ça a
l'air d'être en montagne regardez cette
cette vieille ferme regardez ça si c'est
pas magnifique à ces magnifiques à là on
est bien là on peut on peut faire de
jolis randonnée à mon avis la
grand'combe chateleu avec les benoît les
bagnoles et oui on est toujours surpris
l'angoissé vous ne cessez de monsieur
initialement ce soir mais ses besoins
car nos intérêts ça c'est vrai est-ce
qu'on a autre chose et oui un peu plus
proche de nous en tout cas de l'endroit
où on fait ce live on nous demande roger
sur les spécifications pour la reine
j'ai mis un petit sur votre j'ai
anticipé bourg-la-reine donc dans les
hauts-de-seine on a les résultats déjà
avec un excellent score pour emmanuel
macron c'est peut-être ce qu'on a vu de
plus important depuis le début 83 29 %
des suffrages contre 16,71 abstention
22,69 on a on a mieux voté qu'au niveau
national à bourg-la-reine et on peut
regarder d'ailleurs en 83,29 est ce
qu'il a fait là aussi moins bien qu'en
2017 le président de la république oui
il avait fait 87 77 % en 2017 vous
pouvez comparer les résultats de cette
année vous pouvez même comparé les
résultats avec avec les résultats il ya
dix ans dans l'élection présidentielle
d'il ya dix ans il y avait il ya dix ans
françois hollande est arrivé en tête
juste devant nicolas sarkozy pour
remonter dans le temps avec ce site sur
lefigaro.fr cette lentille
particulièrement intéressant vous pouvez
faire cet exercice aussi chez vous chers
internautes ont
en allant directement sur le site
internet chercher le moteur de recherche
et puis faire cette petite recherche par
vous même mais posez vous la question
oui partager ça avec eux c'est en
allemand comment s'appellent les
habitants de grand combe de grands
comptes chateleu et on peut même voir
les paysages il est 23h30 est ce que on
rappelle aux gens ce qu'on fait ici
comment ça marche c'est l'occasion est
jeu ce soir ce qu'on fait pour vous
c'est tout simplement de vous donner les
résultats dans votre commune vous nous
donnez un nom de commune un autre
département éventuel un nom de code
postal plus exactement et puis à thibaut
recherche en direct sur le moteur de
recherche du figaro.fr le résultat pour
cette commune alors attention on ne vous
donne les résultats qu'une fois qu'ils
sont dépouillés et officiels oui on
rappelle comment ça marche dépouillement
les résultats sont envoyés en préfecture
qui sont envoyées au ministère de
l'intérieur qui sont envoyées ici sur le
site du figaro et puis nous on cherche
sur le moteur de recherche le nom de
votre commune vous voyez on donne un
exemple pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
mais je sais que plein de monde attend
impatiemment me confirme dans le chat
est énormément de gens je salue gamer 60
de ses tubes lefigaro.fr et facebook va
coûter en tout cas sur youtube et sur
facebook nous attendent sont
particulièrement réactif mais fait
plaisir aux gens du figaro.fr quand même
essayé il y en a aussi mais nous
montrent pas de ville de communes a
alors s'ils veulent des avancées sur
l'autre live avec avec vincent roux et
bruno de rennes où on vous donne les
résultats dit moi alors on me demande
par exemple
baggy mort 68 sur le site est tout à
l'heure ça fait plusieurs fois qu'ils
nous demandent
quels sont le quai les résultats de la
présidentielle dans la ville de noyon
dans l'oise noailles alors s'il ira n o
à 12 l es
vous m'avez dit dans
j'en ai plusieurs donc dans l'oise dans
l'oise 81 c'est ça et lancer le tarn le
80 alors attendez je vais rechercher
dans l'oise c'est peut-être le soin
sandri oui bah oui je n'en porte quoi je
tape n'importe quoi dans le 70e noailles
c'est ça dans le 60 exactement marine le
pen 57 24% des voix elle est en tête à
noailles devant emmanuel macron
42,76 % des voix les abstentionnistes
c'est important à l'abstention car on
29,42 français plus élevé qu'au niveau
national à noyon dans l'oise et puis
voith sur youtube ça fait plusieurs fois
également qu'ils nous demandent les
résultats pour cannes a certains qu'on
lisait déjà alors en voici dans la du
mal souvent mais c'est une ville où on a
eu plus grand que ça on a eu en écho en
a eu mais son nez et clermont ferrand
déjà dans les grandes villes
effectivement regardons si on a les
résultats à cannes oui on a les
résultats à cannes emmanuel macron il
est en tête 52 63% des voix c'est assez
serré avec marine le pen 47,37 % des
suffrages abstention à s'élever à on est
au-delà des 30% à cannes regardons ce
qu'il s'était passé il ya cinq ans à
cannes au deuxième soit manuelle macron
était déjà en tête à l'époque mais son
score à un petit peu baissé en cinq ans
et en parlant de grandes villes thibault
en à manon qui nous demande le résultat
pour le 9e arrondissement de paris à
essayant pourquoi pas les voir à 30 de
le découvrir avec c'est un peu du souci
alors c'est pas c'est pas forcément
évident manon je vous respecte pourquoi
tout simplement parce que les bureaux de
vote dans paris et dans les grandes
villes si ça plaît en ferment plus tard
ce qui fait que les votes sont
dépouillés plus tard ils sont remontées
plus tard au ministère de l'intérieur et
nous résultat qu'on vous donne ce sont
ceux qui sont
officiels qui sont entérinés voilà si
nos si ce n'est pas encore le cas si ce
n'est que partiel on vous donne pas le
résultat forcément est non seulement un
peu plus de temps pour les grands
dictionnaires le voyait preuve en image
paris 19ème arrondissement on n'a pas
encore les résultats malheureusement
peut-être dans les plus petits
arrondissement le premier par exemple
voilà pourtant maintenant on avait mis
des fleurs dans son message j'aurais
aimé aurait aimé vous répondre il ya des
gens sympathiques il y en a que des
anneaux de sa fatigue c'est vrai mais ça
j'en doute pas une seule seconde vous
m'avez dit qu'ils étaient très polis en
plus absolument allez on y va en continu
et malheureusement on est désolé on n'a
pas encore les résultats à paris
alors on nous demande les résultats
antoine sur youtube soir antoine le
résultat pour assinie insignia je ne
connais pas à signer écouter et danser
dans le département du cher rajon centre
val de loire alors c'est ici parce que
rire déjà un autre assis ni mais dans le
18 dans le cher 58 voix pour emmanuel
macron ce qui porte son score à 56 86 %
marine le pen 43,2 14% et puis
l'abstention elle est un peu plus basse
qu'au niveau national à assinie dans le
dans le cher j'ai envie de voir à quoi
ça ressemble à signer allons-y si on
voyage est un petit peu je me fais
plaisir assiny alors j'ai plusieurs
assinie ce que c'est le bon oui c'est
dans le cher où ça a l'air très campagne
à assinie regardons où ces jeux des
zooms jeu des zooms jeu des enjeux des
hommes parce que c'est le principe aussi
en voyage un petit pas exactement vous
le voyez orléans ici on est on est on
allé entre bourges dans le triangle
entre orléans auxerre et bourges ah oui
c'est très campagnard c'est là c'est un
peu perdu à signy je me permets de le
dire mais vous êtes vous allez vous
faire des attendait un peu perdu des
fois on est bien dans des endroits car
c'est vrai c'est paris le métro c'est un
c'est pas forcément toujours très bien
regarder on doit être très heureux avait
ni dans le calme d'assinie sanger
exactement allons-y en autre chose juste
vous y
jérémy vous demande les résultats pour
châteauroux t-box châteauroux il ya
beaucoup de châteauroux alors
châteauroux je précise dans le 36
exactement châteauroux dans l'indre
grandes communes châteauroux 43 mille
habitants et les résultats on les a déjà
à châteauroux emmanuel macron en tête 62
milles 62% des voix ce qui fait onze
mille voix à peu près marine le pen est
en deuxième position 37 60 évidemment
l'abstention à s'élever à 1 châteauroux
32,32 % on regarde ce qu'il s'est passé
il ya cinq ans à géra tel bouton mais
j'y reviens doucement en 2017 emmanuel
macron était déjà en tête 71 % il a un
peu baissé également la tendance se
confirme on n'a pas encore trouvé de
communes où le président a fait mieux
que il ya cinq ans c'est vrai c'est un
petit peu la sous-tend un des
enseignements à tirer de cette élection
faudra voir une fois qu'on aura bien
entendu l'ensemble des résultats est ce
qu on a eu notre ville les internautes
nous demande eh bien vous écoutez ça
continue thibault et on est très heureux
n'hésitez pas à continuer à donner des
noms de communes encore et encore on
recherche le début d'accord d'accord
cette
référence
mais je ne pousse pas la chansonnette je
ne fais que citer les paroles allons-y
florian exemple aurions ménagers sur
facebook notamment le résultat pour sa
taille vol de saint-avold une commune
française située dans la moselle
exactement saint-avold et on y va ce
15000 habitants on a les résultats c'est
marine le pen en tête à saint-avold 53%
des suffrages un tout petit peu moins de
47 pour emmanuel macron l'abstention
elle est assez élevée
30,31 % à saint-avold je vous rappelle
qu'on a les concours ce soir parce que
ça fait un moment qu'on n'a pas fait un
point courait et on sait que dès qu'on
est une petite pièce dans la machine aux
internautes de comparer dans le meilleur
pseudo la magie des fous on aime
beaucoup la magie des femmes forcées de
faire mieux que ça le plus joli nom de
villa là vous l'adorez graines en
grenouille c'est la découverte de la de
la soirée la plus petite commune qu'on a
eu à chercher roche fourche à huit
électeurs seulement c'est dans la drôme
sachez quand même mention spéciale on
sait pas dans un concours mais qu'on a
appris qu'il avait une ville qui
s'appelait y tout simplement à jouer les
habitants s'appelait les la lune perdu
ben oui mais je peux pas me faire
confiance en ce sens les ips ilo n'ya
hélas non vous regardez mon carnet je me
souviens comment oublier sachez que la
commune la plus rigolote on a eu des
grivoiseries mennour se concentre sur
autre chose toujours on aime beaucoup la
commune d' arnaque la poste huawei est
une commune qui s'appelle arnac la poste
en france c'est en haute vienne fait
mieux 1 dans tous ces concours je suis
sûr que vous pouvez trouver la plus
petite commune et oui certainement
en attendant nous avons encore de
nombreux internautes qui nous demandent
des noms de communes
des noms de communes qui nous donnent
des noms de communes pour en avoir le
résultat sd c'est sur youtube bonsoir
ils nous demandent si nous avons déjà
des résultats pour villemomble
villemomble si
département la seine saint denis alors
villemomble j'imagine que je
n'allais les résultats trente mille
habitants oui on a les résultats
emmanuel macron assez largement en tête
un 68 58 % des voix marine le pen 31%
forcément comme je répète comme s'il y
allait avoir quelqu'un d'autre que
marine le pen et non c'est le deuxième
tour des présidentielles de candidats
71% on est vraiment très proche de
l'abstention du niveau national au
premier tour c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui est arrivé en tête le report de voix
a donc profité assez largement à
emmanuel macron dans cette commune de
villemomble en seine-saint-denis alors
florian à présent vont soir sur facebook
tout le monde les résultats de zooming
alors c'est un z à timmins 1 timmins à
100 l'alsace aussi effectivement et le
département de la moselle pour mk je
n'ai pas inventé grand chose je suis un
peu dans le cliché je suis le bon
j'avoue jalousie mimiques c'est rigolo
marine le pen en tête à zilling 70% tout
pile emmanuel macron 30% tout pile 245
voix pour l'une 105 voix pour l'autre et
puis l'abstention les assez basses plus
basse qu'au niveau national 23 39%
d'abstention votes blancs et nuls on
peut aussi voir ça ce qui est très
intéressant à voir sur l'ensemble de
cette élection le vote blanc et le vote
nul au second tour on sait que beaucoup
d'électeurs jean luc mélenchon ont dit
non nous on votera blanc ou nul où on
s'abstiendra et bien voilà vous avez
tous les résultats allaient je regarde
ce qu'il s'est passé en 2017 on peut
comparer avec 72% tout pile en 2022 et
j'ai raté le bouton encore décidément
2017 on le voit est bien là progresser
marine le pen elle était à 64 % il y a
cinq ans alors houdré dans le chat
revient ordre et 10 bacs à audrey
exactement et pour notre plus grand
plaisir à nos demandes si nous avons des
résultats de dungy sinclair et lorraine
précise même si beau mais on a déjà
cherché il ya laissé une communauté d'un
guy st clair oui vous vous souvenez
c'est en haute savoie moi je connais
bien je vous ai déjà dit d'un gie
sinclair ces gens non mais ces gens
s'acharnent sur gc à coeur parce que
c'est un village quand même 1438
habitants donc on a eu alors
audrey précise qu'un bon ami lee
convient cet été ah bon et que donc par
conséquent mais vous savez ce qui s'est
passé dans cette commune je veux savoir
où il met les pieds est ce que ça change
doublement je ne comprends pas bien mais
sachez qu'à d'alger sinclar donc on le
redit comme au début de ce chat de ce
live que emmanuel macron est en tête à
dargis sinclair les gens sont un peu un
peu dingo 1 sur d'autres sur notre sur
nos différents chat voilà vous avez qui
nous rejoindront en cours de route
audrey qui par ailleurs nous nous
remercie pour cela et vp on rails que le
figaro produit ce soir vous embrasse
audrey dites moi si vous me sortez une
troisième fois danger sinclair alors
[Rires]
nous demande et je pense que ça va vous
réjouir type mois on retourne dans les
concours un petit peu a alors il ya
barquette attention soyez prêts il nous
demande le résultat pour vies perdues
oui oui c'est une ville j'ai perdu je
alors j'entends que
j'aime beaucoup parce que ville perdue
postule dans l'absolu au nom le plus
rigolo et postule à mon avis pour la
ville la plus petit parce que ville
perdue sachez que ces dons en indre et
loire voilà taïbi tous que c'est tout à
fait ça caille charlie fabert du this is
it à 2 to have il perdurer c'est vrai ça
fait non mais non j'aime beaucoup alors
c'est un peu poétique 1049 habitants
quand même à ville perdue où marine le
pen a gagné
57 62 % des suffrages pour la candidate
du rassemblement national emmanuel
macron lui obtient 217 voix ce qui porte
son total à 42 % voilà et puis
l'abstention 23.44 dans cette commune de
ville perdue en indre-et-loire bravo aux
gamins parce que là ils postulent
gestation idée il détrône pas nos
petites reines en grenouille arnac la
poste mais on aime beaucoup bravo yaba
alors mathieu
plus sérieusement cette fois nos
demandes le résultat pour coran sont en
vercors courants sont alors avec rançon
alors commençons avec deux r mais c'est
un obus
c'est alors co2 allemand ne vous embêtez
pas je les trouvais corrençon-en-vercors
vous entre fort disert exactement dans
les ruelles macron 70 69 % des voix à
marine le pen
29,31 l'abstention très faible
18,85 alors je suis sûr que
corrençon-en-vercors ça doit être très
jolie parce que le vercors c'est une
c'est une région superbe corrençon en
vercors allons-y on regarde évidemment
on place sur une carte corrençon en
vercors dans le massif du vercors jardin
ses photos à ses impressions ses skis
mais oui c'est un tapis roulant vous
savez comme ça on peut monter alors là
c'est super raccord on n'est pas déçu un
peu de ski tout à l'heure vous voulez
aller c'est vrai à mayotte un monoski
c'est un peu tard l'un mais ces
prochaines l'année prochaine on fait
sans elle et chez noté gérard sent qu'on
peut faire du ski nordique plus que du
ski alpin à courrensan la cote et rien
ne nous prend deux tickets pour la
saison prochaine
activement mais regardez-moi ça alors là
oui c'est bucolique un pour le coup là
aussi j'aime beaucoup bravo qui nous
avons demandés ça parce que c'était très
joli c'est d'écouter c'était mathieu
matthieu lamarre maire sur youtube et
puis on vous fait profiter de ses photos
de corrençon en vercors j'imagine une
petite randonnée pendant que là vous me
cherchez la prochaine feu mais dites moi
on va ce sera marié va on va changer
encore dans nombre d'endroits de lieux
c'est maeva sur soi-même à ce bouquet le
monde le résultat pour beaucaire au
caire change totalement d'endroits de
france a occasionné par dans le gard
beaucaire c'est comme ça oui à boca
parce qu'il ya un autre botteur de
beaucaire de beaucaire mais dans ce beau
quercy dans le gard c'est marine le pen
qui est en tête 70 80 2% des voix devant
emmanuel macron 39,18 et puis
l'abstention est un peu plus élevé qu'au
niveau national est ce que marine le pen
fait mieux qu'il ya cinq ans dans cette
commune et on a vu pour l'instant que ce
cas de figure adam khel et à 60 pour
cent cette année il ya cinq ans elle est
et à 55 oui elle fait mieux là aussi
emmanuel macron deiss comme au niveau
national on cherche la commune la
commune où emmanuel macron aura fait
mieux qu'il ya cinq ans en dit moins un
autre chose alors peut-être avec celle
ci thibault saint joseph saint joseph
c'est nova sur youtube qui nous laisse
un peu sur qui en a partout et saint
joseph et à la réunion a alors réunion
c'est 80 97 4 ou 97,2 allah vous me
piéger l a4 alors il nous a donné un
code postal 97 481 voix la c4 1 4 la
réunion donc marine le pen 70 16 % elle
a fait des scores très très important
dans l'est dans les outre mer marine le
pen pour ce second tour emmanuel macron
29 84 % regarder au premier tour c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui lui avait fait un
excellent score cette fois dans les dom
tom c'est marine le pen qui a profité du
report de voix l'abstention elle est
assez élevé un peu moins que ce qu'on a
pu voir dans certains départements
d'outre-mer 33 points 89 % tiens on
voulait savoir si emmanuel macron avait
fait mieux ou moins bien voilà comparons
29.84 cette année et il a cinq ans le
président la république oui
il n'a pas convaincu à exact emmanuel
macron alain joseph mois qu'on puisse
déjà falloir bosser monsieur le
président on n'est pas convaincu par
votre politique allons-y à laurence de
toine décennies sur youtube bonsoir ont
ils nous proposent la commune ayons le
doux nom de bourg-madame bourg madame
alors là oui mais vous ne prouvez vous
souriez je vous entends sourire pour
madame cette fois c'est rigolo que ça
alors attention où il faut un tir est
exactement bourg madame c'est vrai que
j'aime beaucoup bourg-madame département
des pyrénées orientales est serré à
bourg-madame 50 77% des voix pour le
président de la république emmanuel
macron marine le pen la candidate du rn
49 23 % des voix six petites voix
d'écart c'est très serré dans cette
commune ont donné tout à l'heure une
commune pile poil 50 50 c'est à 10
abstentions assez élevé plus qu'au
niveau national à bourg-madame donc dans
les pyrénées-orientales qui peut rentrer
d'autres allègent le note mais je vais
dans notre taux fragiles les plus
improbables je crois que je me suis mis
en tête que arnac la poste ne pouvait
pas être détrôné dans le nom de ville
rigole sur en affaires mais bon c'est
vrai que pour madame si vous voulez je
vous accorde que bourg madame peut être
la ville la plus rigolote beau style m
en haute vienne bon je le note je note
bravo qui nous a donné ça antoine sens
exactement dites moi on a aussi dit sur
youtube bravo antoine
alors ajoutant je vous sens chercher la
commune en fait il ya plusieurs alors je
suis obligé de choisir alors merci à
tous ceux d'ailleurs qui commentent
comment vous faites votre choix aucun
parti pris alors absolument qu'un parti
en vrille parce que vous venez d'où
alors pour ma part je viens parce que
c'est peut-être que je vais avoir une
réponse à toutes ces villes bretonnes
par exemple que vous m'avez sortir du
puy de dôme alors le puy-de-dôme on en a
eu un paquet et bien j'ai grandi figurez
vous offre plutôt je suis né
[Musique]
je suis né en belgique pour ma part et
voilà les résultats notez bien que l'on
n'a pas les résultats des français de
l'étranger mais par ailleurs vous
pourrez évidemment retrouver ses
résultats sur lefigaro.fr dans les
prochains jours exactement ça c'est une
bonne précision merci allemand à l'oise
à autre chose alors oui la de votre
choix tout à fait je c'est compliqué
hein dites de choisir mais c'est que je
sais vous avez tous ces noms de villes
que vous nous proposez allez-y en fait
c'est le mettais plein de noms qui soit
complètement perdu et moi je me régale
je cherche les villes après 10,3 et
consorts sur les civils ou de membres le
résultat pour villeneuve tolosane a
alors prêt toulousain j'imagine
villeneuve tolosane j'ai assez peu de
doute effectivement haute-garonne gelé
avec l'occitan un évidement
villeneuve-tolosane emmanuel macron est
en tête 62 48 % des suffrages marine le
pen arrive donc avec à 37 50 2% on a
plutôt bien voter l'abstention
abstention correct disons 23 39% à
villeneuve tolosane je pense que ce dans
la banlieue de toulouse villeneuve
tolosane serre pendant que vous cherchez
la prochaine ville moi je vais m'amuser
à voir villeneuve tolosane où c'est
exactement
alors je tape regardez on le fait
ensemble oui on sait exactement dans la
banlieue de toulouse dans la banlieue
sud de toulouse des villas côté cugnaux
portet sur garonne on situe on sait où
est donc villeneuve tolosane dites moi
on a eu notre ville alors vous me
demandiez thibault il ya un instant
comment je fais mon choix de vie parmi
toutes les demandes qu'on reçoit c'est
très simple c'est de faire plaisir à
tout le monde alors c'est parce que vous
naviguez entre youtube le figaro.fr et
facebook des gens nés sur plusieurs
canaux effectivement vous avez raison de
le rappeler ce qui fait que ben voilà on
savait beaucoup de réactions et de
commentaires et puis j'essaye de donner
un petit peu la parole à tout le monde
parce que certains des internautes
proposent consécutivement plusieurs noms
de couesnon alors choisissez j'aimerais
répondre à tout le monde rené premier 1
après tout exactement c'est ont
diversifié un petit peu les sources
alors par exemple quelqu'un qu'on n'a
pas encore entendu c'est sur quel site
sur youtube sur le fil sur youtube dites
moi c'est sadrack sadrack qui nous
donnera le résultat pour la joue pas
bouillon la joue peu brouillon qui est
une petite commune comme sains du nord
de la martinique à 880 habitants à joue
pas alors je veux pas d'ancienneté
brouillon exact c'est ce qu'on est en
train de prendre le bouillon c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de prendre oui 4e
devant vous je vous sans perdre une
manche et alors là regardez c'est marine
le pen qui est en tête 58,61 % emmanuel
macron est donc deuxième très
logiquement 41,39 % est ce qu'on a bien
voté suspense on descends descends
descends et non abstention assez
incroyable d'ailleurs 1 57 75 %
d'abstention dans cette commune
c'est très impressionnant 883 ses
électeurs ne se sont pas déplacés dans
sept communes de la martinique allez on
était à la montagne il n'ya pas
longtemps on retourne plus près de la
mer j'imagine ajoupa bouillon regarder à
laon n'a magnifique sur des mois ça
cette petite cascade ça a l'air très
bien ça et oui parce que c'est le
principe aussi de cela ils vont vous les
résultats et puis on en profite pour
voyager entre garder on peut même faire
un peu de canyoning la ajoupa bouillon
ça a l'air très sympa même des gens en
maillot de bain pour ne pas couper le
port de saison non non non non non aller
allons-y en change photos m'ont
contractuels alors antoine vous nous
dites qu'on veut plus vont prendre vos
propositions alors salon le nouveau maxi
ne nous braquer pas avec antoine s'il
vous plaît parce que anton il est là
depuis le début et oui et c'est vrai
exécuté c'est beaucoup demander bon côté
c'est vrai c'est promis antoine on en
reprend encore une avant la fin l'une de
vos propositions avant la fin du reste
une vingtaine de minutes ensemble
maximum donc on a le temps d'en faire
encore un petit peu et entonne empreinte
de vos communes je m'y engage parce que
celui ci est un traitement qu'il a plus
envie de vous faire plaisir vous voilà
le rôle du méchant les jeux
bienvenus le résultat d'un petit porte
un petit port nommés douarnenez
douarnenez hop voilà c'est comme ça
douarnenez jeu léger bien discret
douarnenez mélanie sur facebook dans le
finistère évidemment c'est très joli
aussi douarnenez emmanuel macron y est
en tête dans ce second tour 71 36 %
voilà son score dans pour ce dimanche de
deuxième tour en 2022 marine le pen 28%
abstention ou via un peu plus bas que la
moyenne nationale tient à d'hormones
emmanuel macron il avait fait combien en
2017 quel était son score 80 % et oui là
aussi ça a baissé pour emmanuel macron
tiens on peut même un vous le savez
aller encore plus loin en 2012 c'était
françois hollande qui avait gagné assez
largement devant nicolas sarkozy à
douarnenez alban dites moi une autre
ville alors vincent vincent antoine sur
youtube nous demande le résultat pour
sainte cécile à 106 6 ans cécile commune
française située dans le département de
la manche la manche la manche c'est 50
cc
ce sens d'un manche est
emmanuel macron à sainte-cécile 64 08 %
c'est une petite commune regarder 305
voix pour pour le président 171 voix
pour marine le pen qui porte son
pourcentage à 35,92 l'abstention est
assez basse 21,90 % dans cette commune
de sainte cécile je pense qu'on va
pouvoir avoir de plus grandes villes
maintenant un sourire voulez vous
exactement des plus grandes villes parce
qu'il est 23h50 et maintenant ça y est
on commence à avoir avoir ce genre de
ville j'ai de nouveau de la part de
plusieurs internautes des questions pour
paris thibout a essayé essayons quelque
à l'arrondissement 23h50 il est plus que
temps possible en 91e alors si je tape
14e arrondissement de paris regardez jeu
les hommes c'est un et on a les
résultats vous voyez et ben voilà on a
les résultats à paris on commence à ce
qu'ont ils à la question sur youtube
vous serez content chercher les vous
aussi un cinquante mille personnes ont
voté pour emmanuel macron ce qui porte
son total à 84 69 pour son marine le pen
15% on sait qu'à paris c'est toujours
assez difficile pour la candidate du fn
abstention assez bas si on a plutôt bien
voter dans le dans le 14ème
arrondissement
regardons ce qu'il s'était passé il ya
cinq ans dans le dans le 14ème emmanuel
macron était à 89 là aussi il a un petit
peu baissé le président de la république
on a des grandes villes on a paris vous
pouvez le faire on vous le rappelle vous
allez sur le site
lefigaro.fr et vous trouvez un très
rapidement très rapidement vous pouvez
trouver certaines communes qui sont plus
grandes vous tapez le nom vous trouvez
vous cherchez vous fait plaisir et puis
vous venez avec nous aussi nous on vous
aide on trouve sur les différents chat
allez un petit quart d'heure ensemble
encore exactement si vous voulez des
analyses des commentaires sur l'élection
incertain dans le chatt commandes ce qui
vient de se passer ce soir et bien
n'hésitez pas à parcourir le site
internet le site vous montre par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'on peut on peut voir par
exemple cet article qui vous plaît
beaucoup de jérôme fourquet ça fait
jérôme fourquet qui est
bien que l'idéologue bien sûr ce nouveau
monde à une décomposition politique
avancée d'un entretien avec eugénie
bastille où il analyse un petit peu les
conséquences du scrutin de ce soir et
puis vous pouvez aussi voir des cartes
regarder celle ci par exemple ici c'est
la carte la progression de l'abstention
entre les deux tours en bleu sa abaissé
en rouge ça augmente et on voit qu'il ya
certaines certaines parties du
territoire où l'abstention a augmenté
notamment dans le sud-ouest plus dans le
sud que dans le que dans le nord
visiblement et ses cartes il faut
préciser quelles vont être complétés
tout au long de la soirée énorme travail
de la musique data tout à fait quand
même et ré du fou c'est le ici c'est de
regarder l'abstention ces femmes et ces
équipes on peut voir où on sait plus
abstenus quand ces blancs secs les
résultats ne sont pas encore arrivés
mais ça progressivement se remplir on
voit par exemple qu'on s'est beaucoup
abstenu dans les dom tom et en corse
alors on revient à nos résultats
thibault si vous voyez un cheveu parce
que leurs internautes trépigne
d'impatience quand vous parlez vous
parler mais elle attend des résultats
veut le résultat au kremlin bicêtre
en banlieue parisienne le des humains
disent être dans le val de marne
exactement et on a les résultats là
aussi au kremlin bicêtre emmanuel macron
en tête 77 56 % des suffrages marine le
pen 22,44 ces 2009 140 voix voilà et
abstention très impressionnante un très
impressionnante très importantes plus
importante qu'au niveau national en tout
cas 34,37 % d'abstention dans cette
commune où jean luc mélenchon est arrivé
en tête au premier tour cette fois et
bien c'est emmanuel macron qui a donc
profité de ce report de voix dans ce
second tour des électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon a les seins on va prendre
quand même une proposition d' antoine
antoine bruit on lui a dit on va
toujours la même chose promise chose due
à contre l'adversité d'être avec nous
merci de m'avoir suivi tout au long de
l'histoire c'est le fidèle il doublement
le résultat pour longny au perche dans
l'orne
alors il sort aussi des noms de villes
antoine où vous nous aider parce que là
il est 23h45 je vous avoue qu'on a
commencé il ya plus de deux heures le
marathon touche à sa fin et vous nous
donnez des villes comme salon alors
longue lawn dit l'on dit j'espère que je
prône un règlement l ong y y j'ai tiré
au tir et perches long comme ça comme ça
alors avec un n avant on y voit là
longny au perche exactement top on
trouve longny au perche avec donc marine
le pen qui est en tête pas grand chose 8
178 voix contre 846 ça fait 50 93 d'un
côté
49,07 de l'autre l'abstention elle est
plus basse qu'au niveau national 22 %
seulement à l'eau ni aux perches marine
le pen est ce qu elle avait déjà gagné
en 2017 dans cette commune eh bien non
c'est emmanuel macron c'était aussi
serré mais là aussi le président est en
recul alors sur lefigaro.fr surtout 59
encore un internaute qui nous a rejoint
récemment promis la raison il sait bien
et voilà abonnez-vous au figaro.fr pour
les favoris oui oui oui les analyser
pour participer aussi à ce chat un
immeuble où 59 cherche demande le
résultat de harnes dans le pas de calais
alors attention harnes avec 1h au début
à oui j'ai failli me faire piéger harnes
dans le pas-de-calais commune où
généralement marine le pen fait de très
bons scores on va voir si ça se confirme
dans cette commune de 12000 324
habitants eh oui marine le pen assez
largement en tête 1 65 30 % des
électeurs l'ont choisie dans ce dans ce
second tour emmanuel macron est deuxième
avec 34 70 l'abstention allait aller
dans la moyenne nationale 28% tiens est
ce que marine le pen était déjà en tête
en 2017 on regarde son score 65 37
années et elle était à 61 24 elle a
aussi progressé dans cette commune du
pas de calais à main c'est ça arm
exactement de calais 12000 324 habitants
on peut savoir plein de choses hein on
peut même savoir les impôts le nombre de
foyers fiscaux si ça vous intéresse vous
avez des temps vous pouvez creuser sous
même l'emploi s'est rarement c'est tout
le taux d'activité non non c'est très
très complet et évidemment allons livrer
les équipes du big data
alors man on nous demande le résultat
pour le 9e arrondissement de paris tout
à l'heure on avait certains résultats
donc on peut le penser les vrais tentons
9e arrondissement de paris pour manon
je les regarde et on a eu le 14e tout à
l'heure tout à fait peut-être attendre
les résultats dans le 11e arrondissement
de paris le suspense est insoutenable
nous sommes proches de minuit des
roulements de tambour
très bien oui on a les résultats
emmanuel macron est en tête dans le 9e
arrondissement
pas d'excès pour les résultats d
emmanuel macron ne prend pas parti n'ont
pas semé vous demande si on met pour un
con pour un autre sur youtube alors que
nous n'en a évidemment que non non non
non nous sommes journalistes et surtout
on a voté mais c'était pas notre rôle si
vous voulez des avis vous allez sur
l'autre live du figaro l'aca débat ça
s'engueule un petit peu au tour de
vincent roux et bruno dray nous non nous
on est dans la bonne humeur on vous
donne seulement les résultats et vous
avez le résultat donc dans le 9e
arrondissement avec emmanuel macron
largement en tête 89 0 5% marine le pen
un peu moins de 11% l'abstention elle
est assez basse on a plutôt bien voter
dans cet arrondissement de la capitale
tiens est-ce que emmanuel macron effet
mieux 89 % en 2017 ça on peut le voir
sur le site oui l'état à 92% là aussi il
a perdu on n'a toujours pas trouvé une
commune où emmanuel macron a fait mieux
cette année par rapport à l'élection de
alors on nous demande le résultat pour
privat il va c'est pas dans les halles
d'autres en s'inscrivant c'est donc dans
la wehrmacht l'ardèche l'ardèche et la
personne qui nous le monde nous dit que
c'est la plus petite préfecture
préfectures de france voilà voyez on n'a
plus besoin de noms mais on n'a même pas
besoin de chercher nos internautes ont
déjà le titre préfectures de france sur
scène pour nous il c'est vrai il n'ya
pas donc connais pas d'autres grandes
communes en ardèche prix va donc elle en
effet combien d'électeurs pas beaucoup
60% des voix pour emmanuel macron avec
2060 voix marine le pen 39 64 et puis
l'abstention elle est assez élevé à
privas 1 30 et 1
56% privat à l'ardèche moi ça ça me fait
penser vous savez où la crème de marrons
j'adore ça je crois à vous aussi ah oui
alors je sais pas si c'est pas de brive
à la crème de marron
je vais regarder prix va
vous regardez moi cette petite commune
je vous propose de prendre une crème de
marron en sortant de ce live sur une
petite crêpe c'est parfait ah ah oui et
dont m il est pas leur suffit de
regarder pendant que vous me dites la
prochaine commune moi je circule dans
privat parce que regarder c'est
magnifique on a autre chose alors oui
zemmour est sur youtube alors on a
compris pour qui elle va être pour le
coup nous on nous demandait si on
extrait de l'errance zemmour est dit
nous il n'y aura pas votre candidat au
deuxième tour nous demandent ils ou
elles nous demandent plutôt elle je
pense le résultat pour villeneuve alors
mais oui mais villeneuve à leur vie ne
va attendait puisque daily mail
permettez moi de vous dire il y en a un
certain nombre dans le 59 est ce
possible
alors pourquoi pas oui oui villeneuve
dans le 59 à ce que j'ai ça non alors
j'ai pas ça ils n'ont alors est ce que
vous pourriez nous préciser s'il vous
plaît zemmour est et les l'endroit
exactement parce que c'est à mon avis ça
doit être un villeneuve quelque chose
vous savez pas ce que l'âge et que les
villeneuve regarder villeneuve lécussan
en 1900 nicolas magie noire il faut que
j'aie un peu plus de précision est mort
est dites nous tout la villeneuve d'ascq
me préparais venosa oui oui non mais on
a déjà cherché vous n'étiez pas avec
nous et moi mais vous avez raison nous
rejoindre que vous redonner les
résultats leur d'ascq alors comment je
les écris tout à l'heure parce que je
les trouvais dans la banlieue de lille
sous alors d apostrophes à alès sécu
alors pourquoi je devrais toujours rage
devrait pouvoir retrouver la vie le dos
quand même il ya peut-être un petit tir
et voilà ans villeneuve tirait des
apostrophes d'ascq jeu si ce pourquoi je
ne comprends pas ouais
je suis perdue alors villeneuve d'ascq
je suis pas content est ce que vous
pouvez me dire mon cher alban parce que
je sais que vous êtes sur internet dit
moi le code postal de villeneuve alors
je suis en train de le chercher salle
ainsi devoir se trouver sa ville doivent
d'ascq
ab je les mets voir et peu c'est tout
simple il suffit de demander il était
capricieux un lieu aussi on vient de
passer minuit ils avaient ils avaient
plus envie notre petit moteur d'un char
pis il a toujours envie marche très bien
vous pouvez chercher emmanuel macron en
tête à villeneuve d'ascq 72% des voix
devant marine le pen 27 16 % des voix
abstention un peu au dessus du niveau
national 30 % à villeneuve d'ascq même
si c'est un département le nord qui vote
assez bien pour marine le pen c'est
emmanuel macron dans la banlieue de
lille qui est en tête dans cette commune
allait il est minuit une once est quoi
une dizaine de minutes à l'est et alors
je donne quand même une dernière fois
nos concours pour ceux qui veulent
rattacher la victoire sur le fil la
magie des fous c'est lui qui a le
meilleur pseudo depuis le début de la
soirée rennes en grenouille le plus joli
nom de ville que nous ayons eu à
chercher depuis le début cette soirée
rouge fourche à huit électeurs c'est la
plus petite commune c'est dans la drôme
ahmat la poste en haute-vienne que
j'aime beaucoup qui est le nom le plus
rigolo et vous aimez beaucoup bourg
madame je le sais mais c'est votre petit
côté grivois je voulais faire mieux vous
nous mettez une commune on cherche on
voit si vous pouvez intégrer l'un de ces
vins de ces concours big band puis je
vous rappelle toute dernière fois le
principe de ce live si vous nous
rejoignez juste à l'instant c'est très
simple vous nous donnez un nom de
communes éventuellement un code postal
et puis on recherche on dirait qu
thibout recherche en direct pour vous le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
dont sept communes allez on a autre
chose oui sur facebook eve nous demande
le résultat pour carpentras eve lève toi
il est non elle m'intéresse à janec
très heureux de partager une passion
pour la chanson jours et les semaines
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai soyez là
dedans de mal faire alban elle veut
quelle commune eve alors elle voulait la
commune de carpentras elle me précisait
qu'elle me précisait carpentras les
fraises je pense que ça n'existe pas
elle même si avec la fraise de
carpentras oui oui oui un an mais si
elle précise quand même parce que il ya
des communes comme ça comme la
porcelaine de limoges les melon de
cavaillon les faits vrais carpentras on
aime beaucoup les bêtises de cambrai
vous pouvez donner d'un nouveau concours
en dernière minute les villes au grand
damne spécialité à carpentras et marine
le pen qui en tête 51,35 % des voix
devant donc emmanuel macron très
logiquement 48,65 c'était très serré 332
voix d'écart et une abstention plus
élevé qu'au niveau national vous le
voyez dans cette commune de carpentras
dans le vaucluse voyons voir ce qu'il
s'est passé en 2010 est à carpentras et
emmanuel macron qui est en tête et là
aussi il a perdu des voix des électeurs
dans cette commune du vaucluse en autre
chose merci sève on la remercie merci
beaucoup et puis nous si on aime le
fraises même si la référence à la
chanson elle a pas l'air elle n'a pas
l'air d'avoir
pris de l'excuser elle nous dit bien des
saisies mais non ah oui
je voulais certainement comme vous
voulez écoutez moi je trouvais la
tentative en test merci ce qui me
concerne le rassurer
encore un autre endroit à un autre lieu
en france bajamont lucien pardon sur
facebook nous demande aussi un beau
résultat pour bajamont pour l'allemagne
jamais jamais b agi à m om tu exactement
tout à fait bajamont c'est dans le
lot-et-garonne et donc à bajamont c'est
emmanuel maintenant qui est en tête vous
le voyez 53 48 % devant marine le pen
c'est assez serré parce que c'est une
petite commune
284 voix pour le président de 147 pour
la candidate du rassemblement national
abstention assez faible
20,27 à bajamont dans le lot et garonne
ce magnifique petit département on a
autre chose oui elle aime main sur
youtube nous demande le résultat pour la
roche sur foron h connais vous savez que
je suis et d'autres saveurs
la roche sur foron je vois très bien
alors il ya beaucoup de la roche
voudrais rencontrer quelques vins rouges
la roche sur fond la roche sur foron
pour pas vous mentir c'est pas le plus
jeune est peut-être maintenant cette
information moi alors clm hellemmes bits
et les youtube mettons nous d'accord
vous et moi pas la plus jolie commune
mais on va montrer quand même la roche
sur foron emmanuel macron
64,85 % des voix très bon score pour le
président marine le pen 35,15
l'abstention allait à 25,82 vous m'avez
demandé les photos de la roche sur foron
et bien je vous les montre c'est dans la
vallée vous savez c'est pas dans les
montagnes on imagine toujours mais bon
la roche-sur-foron ça peut être aussi
très jolie à vivre on y vit très bien
pour le coup alors sur foron regardez
cette petite commune j'avoue que je suis
râlons raison à laurent l'otc mais
j'avoue que j'ai un trailer mauvaises
langues allez je retire tout ce que j'ai
dit la roche sur foron avec ses
montagnes et ses vertes prairies à perte
de vue et ses châteaux vous voyez
magnifique la roche-sur-foron je retire
pardon il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de n'y
a pas d'endroit pas jolie en france
l'est certainement où je vous annonce
certainement je ne me permettrais plus
près vous prie m'excuser alors dis qu
sur youtube nous demande le résultat
pour le puy de dôme alors c'est un
département entier on va pas pouvoir
vous donner les résultats essayons mais
musée romain le puy de dome en fait
alors pas ce que vous devez savoir dicko
qu'on ne peut vous donner les résultats
d'un département qu'une fois que
l'ensemble des résultats sont connus ce
qui même à cette heure avancée de la
soirée n'est pas encore forcément
évident eh bien figurez vous que dans le
puy de dôme nous avons les résultats et
bien thibault dans le puy-de-dôme
c'était manuel mâcon tout à l'heure on a
eu les résultats à clermont donc
évidemment on peut avoir les résultats
dans certains départements à cette heure
avancée 00h06 on reste encore cinq
minutes ensemble et vous voyez dans le
puy de dôme dans l'ensemble de ce
département emmanuel macron est donc en
tête 76 % devant marine le pen
39,84 est-ce qu'on a voté dans le puy de
dôme
abstention 24,88 oui on a mieux voter
coq au niveau
national résultats du 1er tour c'est
emmanuel macron tiens on va voir allez
on se permet de comparer emmanuel macron
il a fait 60 % cette année dans le puy
de dôme il avait fait 71 il est en
baisse assez largement recours en grâce
à nos nouveaux c'est vraiment une
tendance générale les gamins sur youtube
nous demandent avec insistance il est
presque désespérée cette source il
comprend un gamin on vous le donne et
après vous pouvez aller vous coucher et
comprendre ce qu'il est tard demain
travail installé lundi et je pense que
cet internaute vise le concours puisque
il nous dit un des concours en tout cas
vous avez celle-ci beau ce soir il nous
demande le résultat pour la ville de
salies d'eau sale gosse oui oui c'est
une jolie insultes [ __ ] mais c'est
plus délicat quoi c'est pas bon alors
comment ça s'écrit comme ça salit gosses
alors c'est lio c'est exact je comprends
c'est dans les hautes-pyrénées je pense
qu'on prononce le s1 je pense je pense
je pense emmanuel macron 54 90 % des
voix 28 voix c'est une petite commune
marine le pen 47 40 5,10 pour 123 voix 5
voix d'écart dans cette commune
l'abstention elle est de 34 74 allez on
en prend encore 3 ça vous dit allez
encore trop à l'étroit les trois
chanceux qui seront les trois chanceux
antoine d'assinie nous demande nous
propose plus tôt
de regarder les résultats pour la ville
de bisous ah
oui un peu de temps voilà on aurait
presque dû finir par ça
mais alors je trouve pas ça alors alors
attention bisous oui j'ai regardé bisous
mais c'est avec un z à pays z os nous
sommes dans notre département de l'orne
alors n'y a pas de s on est là dans
l'orne à bisous alors vous avez un seul
bisous sans s avec marine le pen 57 voix
ce qu'il apporte à
58,76 emmanuel macron avec 40 euros est
à 41 24 % des suffrages abstention
faible seulement 19 abstentionnistes à
bisous dans l'orne 14
84% je me permets pas de vous faire un
bisou on a encore en panne coville bon
ils résistent
voilà alors voilà à l'e p2
professionnalisme allez plus que vous ou
alors celle ci c'est je pense que ce
sera c'est d'emblée la prononciation la
plus compliquée de la souris à l'envers
parce que vous vous êtes planté tout à
l'heure on est alors là je vous est cher
un peu maltraité sur nos différents chat
à cause de vos bêtises appliquez-vous
albon s'il vous plaît il reste alors
fait ça bien valentin nous demande les
résultats pour la ville de
niederschaeffolsheim
voilà niederschaeffolsheim
n'a absolument aucun sens qui m'a dit il
faut battre
à oui alors je savais quoi regarder non
mais alors là c'est quasiment impossible
il communes situées forcément dans le
bar a fait ça va retarder
internautes pervers parce que à mon avis
va l'entendre n'a rien à faire des
résultats annie d'heure schaaf holtzheim
mais nous avons des autonomes créatifs
oui c'est vrai alors alors oui alors je
lai leader vous l'avez d'écouté vache
folle nous avons triomphé ni darshan
nina permettent pardon pardon aux
habitants de niederschaeffolsheim rocha
mois mais votre action est excellent à
ce que je peux mon cher allemand
emmanuel macron il est en tête ça c'est
l'information que tout le monde
attendait
emmanuel macron 51 24 marine le pen
48,76 % dans cette commune du bas rhin
on n'est pas surpris ça peut pas être
ailleurs en france que dans le bas-rhin
allez on le dit une dernière fois dites
le aussi chez vous niederschaeffolsheim
niederschaeffolsheim oui c'est pas mal à
laisser la dernière a laissé la toute
dernière sera le gage en profite pour
pour noter
valant plusieurs de nos internautes vous
vous remercie thibault assez pauvre en
primaire fort soleil ont fait pas
vincent antoine b couteau on est très
content merci d'être resté avec nous
toute la soirée en tout cas où une bonne
partie de la soirée puis n'hésitez pas à
regarder sur lefigaro.fr il ya
énormément de choses à lire et à
apprendre sur le résultat de cette
élection je vous le fais pas dire à tous
derniers résultats donc oui beau et bien
ce sera bibine m sur youtube qui nous
demande le résultat en est exactement
ces jolies aussi il nous d'apprendre le
résultat pour la ville de saint-avertin
puisque c'est bien connu un averti en
vaut deux oui avoue finissait très fort
et je note que vous feignez c'est très
fort un avertin à vos deux en vaut deux
et un avorton ici on sait bien qui sait
aller c'était manuel macron qui est
arrivé en tête à saint-avertin avec 5513
voix ce qui porte son pourcentage à
74,08 marine le pen 25,92 trois quarts
un quart dans cette commune d'indre et
loire l'abstention elle est assez basse
20,66 et donc on finit avec
saint-avertin je veux faire un petit
plaisir quand même je vais finir et je
vais choisir la dernière commune le
mesnil mitri qui est la commune la plus
petite que nous ayons eu à trouver il y
a deux semaines et regarder ensemble
découvrons le mesnil mitri trois voies
pour emmanuel macron avec 75% des voix
et marine le pen une voix à 25,1 soleil
il n'ya pas d'abstentionnistes la
semaine là il y avait un abstentionniste
et bien figurez vous qu'ils l'ont trouvé
ils sont allés chercher à mon ami mais
pour les embêter il est venu à 17h58 feu
au bureau de vote soit resté jusqu'au
bout voilà pour cette petite commune bon
on fait le point quant même allemand sur
nationaux concours qui a gagné alors
thibault bon la magie des fous même si
on les a régalés ça ce sont le meilleur
pseudo de la soirée félicitations
le nom le plus joli alors ça c'est la
découverte de la soirée rennes en
grenouille oui c'est ou en mayenne il me
semble alors rennes en grenouille je
verrai si on me semble que c'est en
mayenne rennes en grenouille répondre ou
alors serait pas pérenne en grenouille
c'est rennes comme la ville de rennes
jean
reinhardt grenouille on aime beaucoup
ses ou 17 ans c'est dans le département
de la mayenne voilà déjà la souvenez
donc roche pour chat même si on a
regardé le mini le vitry roche pour
chats dans la drôme huit électeurs c'est
la plus petite commune que vous nous
avez demandé de chercher
mention spéciale pour y un an y la ville
dans la somme les ipso les ips aux
lignes et non ipso oui c'est ça est il
utile souligne assez exactement des
habitants de y et puis alors on a un
conflit ah oui nous ne sommes pas la
chorale dont le nom le plus rigolo de
vie et les bourg madame et selon moi
c'est arnac la poste a en haute vienne
il y à une ville en france qui s'appelle
arnac la poste voilà ce qu'on pouvait
dire on en a fait beaucoup j'aimerais
savoir on va regarder combien la fedil
merci de nous avoir suivis parce que
c'était super vous nous avez beaucoup
aidé ça vous allez allemand et d'écouté
c'était parfait c'était un plaisir
d'animer ce ce chat avec vous et puis
surtout merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis tout au long de la soirée de nous
avoir alimenté en ce que ces communes on
n'est pas grand chose mais pas c'est
vrai on aurait fait vos communes en
belgique mais y'a même pas
ça n'aurait pas été toutes les villes de
neuchâtel ile-de-france et l ile de
france nord et l'île de france la haute
savoie et qui en auraient assez
rapidement fait le tour bon merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve évidemment sur sur figaro là
ils vont continuer ensemble à des bris
fier parce que c'est pas tout à fait
finie même si on sait qu emmanuel macron
et donc le président de la république
pour cinq années plus mais on continue à
parler de politique on parle de tous les
sujets sur figaro live on se retrouve
très bientôt mais des demeures servir du
matin d'ailleurs oui j'aurais sur le
pont soyez là sa saison le matin on
débrief cette élection encore encore et
encore parce qu'on veut tous avoir en
fera le point sur les abstentionnistes
on aura plus de résultats tous ça va
s'achever au long de l'ennemi et à
mesure merci beaucoup excellente soirée
excellente nuit on se retrouve très vite
sur firelight venu à tous